count down with me going live in five
four three two
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one
excuse me sir
it's happening
[Music]
it's not your fault
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
cut it out right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I am a Muslim I am Jewish I am black I
am disabled I am gay
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Neil bent over this happened somebody
know
[Music]
[Applause]
s
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
we do about it what do we do about it
what do we do about it
what do we do about it one what do we do
about it what do we do about it what do
we do about it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
can you hear me hello
can you guys hear me okay
what's up
nice
welcome everybody
to anything else
anything else let's keep it going
all right all right all right all right
maybe maybe not no more no more else
all right so we have a great show
planned we've been working our buns off
to make it a great show
thank you thank you last night I had 103
fevers so bear with me you know
yeah yeah yeah
I was dying
hey
yeah all right all right hey hey hey
you guys can't be cheering louder for
Ian then for me okay
tone it down all right
keep it bring it down a couple decibels
free in all right
um yeah last night I was uh out my
undies mm-hmm
I had ice on my forehead
in my mouth
man I wasn't a pretty sight was it
it was okay it was nice
oh thank you what do we do about it I
wasn't sure but I'm I'm feeling okay and
I've gotta thank God we live in the age
of Tylenol man
[Applause]
yo who invented Tylenol let's give a
shout out
[Music]
[ __ ] Legend
I'm reading chat
what's that
from chat
yeah the Chatter's here yeah but [ __ ]
Tylenol rules y'all should try it
sometimes [ __ ] ever
um so let's just give it up first of all
for the crew Everybody join us and
everyone's been working so hard
to put the show on
Ela Klein
uh what was your name again
Sam
who is Sam who is Sam
we know who Sam we love Sam Ian of
course
you know not too loud
the people love Ian
say something for Christ's sake talk to
the people they love you I I miss the
queue to come out I missed the cube
I'm gonna clap those cheeks later
tonight you know it's good for you
a b everybody loves a b
a b the boxing Wonder
oh [ __ ] spilling water everywhere [ __ ]
a b the boxer how you feeling feeling
good thank you everyone for coming out
yeah you're training for new another
fire right
I cannot confirm nor tonight at this
time
Oh I thought it was confirmed
I thought it was confirmed that you're
training for another fight
the voice of the
Dan can I confirm that
I can't see you Dan I don't like it
honestly I'm being blinded hi there he
is
he's like these lights are super bright
and I can't see you Dan so it makes me
uncomfortable
Dan is my guard rails
Dan can I can I confirm or deny ab's
boxing match jacket oh
that's not helpful at all Dan
I will be boxing again I just can't say
what event's gonna be yeah yeah yeah
Cameron who came out in his um
Playboy Bunny outfit
you want to give us a twirl Cameron
what was that you want to give us a
twirl a twirl sure yeah yeah
[Applause]
foreign
looking like a snack
I'm gonna break me a piece of that off
later I I put on gym shorts earlier
because AB said he saw my balls
yeah I did that's why we do uh
that's why we test the shots maybe you
saw your balls yo what'd they look like
through underwear through underwear but
they looked uh photoshopped
damn you got those Photoshop balls
very spherical spherical ball yeah very
spherical yeah we had to Jimmy my shot a
little bit because it was all Bradley
Martin crash time show my shot yeah this
[ __ ] is not good no no moving up I'm
gonna have to cross my legs like a lady
it still doesn't help yeah okay enough
of that hey no up hey no upskirts I'm
just kidding you're good Lena of course
is here everybody loves you know yes yes
Lena
she's the best yes Olivia God bless
wow
wow
Olivia
thank you thank you
[Applause]
oh is your is her mic on
[Music]
I love you guys
there it is
and of course this sound Master himself
thank you Zach
Zach
[Music]
yeah thanks
yeah
[Applause]
Ethan
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
oh yeah and who could forget the robot
all the way out in Sweden
the master of kebab
love
it's love
we all love love
's out there looking like an orthodox
Jew right now I don't know why
thank you guys but we love that for him
how's what time is it out in uh in
Sweden right now love oh it's like 6 a.m
I like that
dude you have the most [ __ ] up work
hours ever dude yeah it's bad it's bad I
need to get to ASAP we love you
you're going to be out here sooner
sooner or later you know hopefully yeah
one way or the other thank you
oh yeah
either in person or in a [ __ ] body
bag
we're gonna get you out here
oh yeah
oh yeah and of course Dan I mean my
goodness
damn
yes hello
hello
[Applause]
oh my goodness
oh my goodness it's white claw game
[Applause]
[ __ ] Fried Chicken
Fried Chicken Wednesday [ __ ]
wait
Santa Claus is coming to town Santa
Claus is Coming to Town
[Applause]
let's go
Gabe how you doing
you have presents for everybody
it's coming out you know why because who
the [ __ ] is Uncle game who the [ __ ] is
gay who the [ __ ] is the first game who
the [ __ ] is Uncle gay yeah [ __ ] my man
[Applause]
okay yeah
wow you know you you forget Dan actually
does have a job
he's back there you all don't really
necessarily have a job at all
me neither
Dan's out there Fried Chicken hey it
hurts
[Applause]
I heard some of y'all were here like
pretty early
really
you guys got here at four
all right
[Music]
want to be first in line but your seat's
not even that good
[Applause]
there's two seats here you guys want to
sit here
[Applause]
[Music]
y'all can't show up at two and then sit
like in the middle
chicken that's some [ __ ] Ethan Ethan
unless are someone's supposed to sit
there oh wait hold on someone's supposed
to sit there who's sitting there
oh no you guys sit there we'll figure it
out I'll figure it out
[Music]
there already
yeah whoa whoa whoa wait wait wait wait
wait appears to be handing yo Gabe what
are you doing out there white cloud
Gabe's in the aisle
Clark Gabe
are you handing out Fried Chicken
Chicken [ __ ]
but it's
but it's Tuesday
Tuesdays I don't give a [ __ ] give me my
[ __ ] Fried Chicken is for is for
Wednesday
oh yeah he
yeah sorry he's Gathering up the Fried
Chicken
sorry game
yeah
[Applause]
I think Gabe thought it was Wednesday
but then he had to come gather up the
fried chicken
yeah sorry about that
we love him though I just served fried
chicken yeah we deserve Fried Chicken it
doesn't matter you know what Gabe you
can Gabe Gabe Gabe okay
share the chicken with the people
[Applause]
who wants chicken
[Applause]
are you guys ready what
foreign
[Applause]
oh so Ethan you you had 103 degree fever
and you just started throwing chicken
out through a bunch of people in the
public I just wanna
point that out
Dan I cannot hear you I was just
pointing out you do have a 103 degree
fever and you're
you're wrong yeah don't eat that
it's a Keepsake just saying
it's memorabilia not food
it's a prank Dan it's a prank all right
I'm gonna have a seat I'm feeling hot
it might be a few I'm not I don't have
covet by the way
so guys we have a great show planned
um
yeah I know sorry
all right listen
oh my lap so hold on I gotta fix my shot
here
how are you feeling now oh I'm fine
thank you yeah
I'm just [ __ ] up on top here he's
better today yeah
I said you're better today right
yeah I'm feeling you know yeah I'm
feeling better yeah
I'm feeling gay
I'm feeling good I felt worthless yeah I
felt gay
I was gonna say I felt I like I had a
fever but he took the words right out of
my I felt gay for sure
yeah so anyway okay
let's get to the show first of all I do
want to announce we had a raffle a
winner
um of the golden cards you guys remember
we did that giveaway the winner is here
today Audrey
yeah we want to stand up
congratulations to Audrey
the winner of the golden ticket
thank you thank you
and and when you unwrap that that sweet
little
Chocolate Factory silly Zonk how did you
feel
thank you so much we love you
yeah we flew up we flew Audrey and their
friend out to join us for the live show
and thanks for being here we love you
guys congrats
hey did you guys hear about um now I
I feel like I've been on The Cutting
Edge of Salt Bay hate
I have never believed in Salt Bay
in fact you know I don't know who's
responsible for him becoming a thing but
it's not me and I would like to know who
it is
was it one of you Ian thoughts
yeah so I don't know if you guys saw but
Salt Bay was getting slammed on because
he was he was [ __ ] around with the
World Cup trying to do his Salt Bay
memes on it but he [ __ ] up
he took it too far he took it to the
World Cup people don't [ __ ] around with
the World Cup
Dan are you gonna play
right right okay disabled
right
Dan are you pulling this up yeah you
wanna put it on screen go ahead
first of all he's touching the legend
messy you know the winners look how he's
holding his arm down bro oh my God
like you flick you literally sprinkle
salt on steaks and you're trying to grab
onto Messi's arm like you even can hold
a shadow to him
he took it too far oh my God he he flew
the [ __ ] stake too close to the Sun
now the whole world's turned on him what
do you guys think about this it's crazy
right salt Goblin
[ __ ] over salted that [ __ ]
you know you should have just had a he
should have just enjoyed his restaurant
his 500 Stakes should be the next one
maybe or not AP Dan
Wherever You Are
yeah this one was bad though
because Messi's like God right now you
can't [ __ ] wrong with that
[Music]
[Applause]
Dan are you gonna pull up the next one
how's this working
all right
Okay so
all right
[Music]
[Music]
all right she's getting bears
I gotta say there's so many so many
Teddy freshers here thank you
thank you
that's awesome love to see it I see you
yeah
the OG grayscale windbreaker don't eat
that chicken bro I'm serious
that [ __ ] ain't right don't [ __ ] eat
it what
yeah put in resin or something
don't eat it thank you you want that
resin I got you oh
okay got a little side action going here
just like that wash your hands wash your
hands
um
Ela tried to get me to dress up and I
you almost got me he almost did but I
was like I laid up stuff for him in his
closet I was like okay you got this
right and I was gonna go down stairs and
I was like do you need to wait you need
me to wait for you and he said no I got
it and then he comes downstairs looking
like that
I said hell no I'm sorry what happened
this is my show
I'm not wearing no damn
tight if it doesn't have elastic waist
I'm at this point stage in my life where
I'm not wearing it
I don't care if it's a funeral I'm
[ __ ] wearing elastic ways look if
it's my funeral if it is my funeral you
better Goddamn be an elastic waste
anyway uh
salt based stuff Dan you want the second
video all right
all right you got you got it you got it
bro you got it
how do you get down there on the field
you just pacing a lot of money like how
the [ __ ] did Salt Bay get down there
he's in stabbing range
of the most famous man in the world
right now
and you've seen he's he's pretty good
with those knives yeah
carve him up like a [ __ ] T-Bone
so that's that's not a threat distance
from the other one what that's another
instance of him trying to grab Messi
yeah bro he's grabbing a touching like I
generally don't know how you get down
there yeah I mean it's following him
around yeah it was like all families on
the field he just kept following him
yeah
yeah he's got too much money we got to
take the money from South Bay and give
it back to the people
Salt Bay is the the one being messy in
this situation
[Applause]
and by the way
I don't know if anybody said this but
there ain't no way that dude is
seasoning those steaks properly you
can't be dropping salt on willy-nilly
and expect it to be seasoned properly
that's a [ __ ] joke
sorry I can't hear very well from up
here
foreign
yo even my water bottle got erectile
dysfunction
[Music]
[ __ ] life's not fair
work with me people
don't push all right Dan is there
anything else yeah there's another one
it's a little bit at the top of the show
uh yeah here let's see oh man
[ __ ] how dare you touch the
trophy no he doesn't just touch it look
at him
stop
no don't think it's all about it
dude
you she should go to jail for this crime
oh baby
we need to lock something up for this
why just go away why I think Salt Bay is
over after this he's the world is turned
against him he placed his lips on the
World Cup
this is assault
nice thank you
yeah so I'm glad the world finally
caught up on me in Salt Bay but I do on
I do dislike most people so I don't know
if it's that unique that I like him
I am a hater ass [ __ ] thank you yeah I
come to my own shows where the audience
to be screaming hater ass [ __ ] to me
thanks [ __ ] yeah bro you're right
it's proud is there anything I'll Stand
and we can move on to
we got all kinds of fun stuff here
no
birthday
[Applause]
[Music]
it's not my birthday
42 42
42 42 42
42. I'm not it's not my birthday
you're wrong oh are you guys cut the
music Zach it's not his birthday okay
thank you finally Dan came around to it
I'm not 42 for the record
oh
it actually was Ila's birthday happy
birthday thank you it actually was
Sheila's birthday recently
no
you guys are gonna get me in jail with
these traps it was about to be 13 and me
60.
Chris Hansen's in the audience
that's the special surprise no cookies
for you no no please just a cupcake
EDP anyone
yeah so anyways
okay so moving on uh let's see here okay
so
every year we like to celebrate a little
thing called Craig's Miss yeah
and seeing as it's Christmas our very
own resident Santa Claus named Ian
Slater
put together has gone uh let's let's say
he's been in the factory with his elves
cooking up some
some gifts
we've been in the trenches uh Sam might
have put her
most diabolical work together on this
one I think uh yeah yeah it's true it's
true I'm so proud of it I can't wait
yeah there's a I walked in on you making
one piece that blew my tits right off me
dude it's so funny but um I say let's
just get right into it um
let's celebrate Christmas merry
Christmas everybody yeah tis the season
[Applause]
the story with Craig's Miss
right happy Hanukkah right for the Jews
right Kwanzaa
[Music]
yeah every you know
I'm not I'm not doing a war on Christmas
now what I'm not doing you know what I
mean no Kanye
Christians are welcome here
foreign
about Hitler bro I
I'm literally said I'm giving the
Christians a shout out Kanye what do you
want
that Kwanzaa we believe in Jesus Christ
you are wrong bro I don't know what he
wants for me he can't win yeah but we we
celebrate Craig's Miss because obviously
we're on a budget and so Ian goes out to
Craig's List
and finds presents for all of us on the
lowest budget possible I think the first
year you spent close to zero yeah this
year you actually were working with a
bit of a budget isn't that right Ian
yeah there was uh there was some
authorizations on some of this yeah uh
we went big we're big this time we went
big
so uh yeah should I just should I go
yeah so I see we've got um Zach up first
here on the list yes
Zach oh [ __ ] it was always happy with
what he gets yeah I'm happy uh
so I don't know if you guys remember
um last time Zach well I got him a
beautiful delicious steak nope
um and he just spit on on my existence
really you're goddamn right what
happened there was a lot of trim on
tremble last year with the Craigslist
there was a lot of steak beef I don't
know Zach would you like to steak beef
yeah
yeah what you gave me was like buried
with a dead guy or some [ __ ] like that
oh it had a curse it had a curse you
give me curse [ __ ] it was why it was
cursed with my love actually but right
that's kind of that is is that a curse
Sam Ian's love
[Music]
wow they're in love aren't they she's
lying
uh well so actually I had a and I've
been telling Zach I had a huge surprise
planned uh there was actually going to
be a giant box on stage and a special
guest was going to emerge from the box
would you can you our Dan can you roll
that video that yeah from the person
that
backed out somebody [ __ ] us someone
ruined Craigslist actually happy
holidays
so we want to wish you a happy Hanukkah
and Zach make sure to smoke your
marijuana now someone true at H3 may
think I'm the world's worst but Zach
today Ethan is giving you the golden
curse of fomo Jesus
so
I workshopped that video with Jimmy
about seven times and he still got it
very wrong
um and he sent me a three-minute song by
the way we had to cut that actually uh
copyrighted probably yeah yeah yeah
um it's very talented it was an Adam
Sandler parody song yeah he's a really
talented musician that's the crazy thing
about Jimmy's no he shreds man yeah
definitely sure great guy so Zach sent
some you know we usually curse you on
Craigslist I wanted to give you a
opportunity here
um I have two gifts on the stage there's
this sort of triangular one right here
yeah and then this tall rectangular one
over there okay one of these gifts is
really [ __ ] cursed it's actually very
bad
and one of them is a delicious steak
from Sizzler
whoa Sizzler
now interesting this is your your
decision Zach you get to select so let's
take a look here so his options are tall
rectangle it's all rectangle big square
or the big triangle what are we thinking
here if we had to pick one out if we
were looking for the steak or the curse
let's reason through this uh come here
come in front here if you could squeeze
by there
now what are we thinking here
you got to get in the mind of Ian a
little bit to anticipate his Dark
Twisted bind I like the triangle
you peeling the triangle
now can I I have an idea
now you wouldn't expect a steak to be in
the Triangle no which is why Ian would
put it in the Triangle that's right
that's the possibility
that line of thinking and double reverse
it
now can I shake him can you shake him no
no no shaking no touching no no touching
and now smelling smelling yes
what I did I thought I smelled something
I think I think I'm gonna go for the
triangle triangle okay all right let's
open it up why don't you go ahead and
let's see what we got bring her out
why don't you just pop pop it open right
here right here oh my goodness
the triangle
could be a beautiful place we gotta get
a shot of it so how do we
can y'all see that can we uh
yeah there you go bring get up right all
man yeah good thank you all right Zach
go ahead rip that open
oh oh that's not oh no oh that's not
looking like a
song
come on bro oh Zach's mistake oh my God
what the [ __ ] that
Zach you gotta own this bro you picked
it
that means it picked you
unwrap it
[Music]
oh wow that is [ __ ] insane
keep popping it open let's see what we
got here
why are you touching it don't touch it
all right the people gotta see you
you're taking a home what do you mean
get it home what's the background on
this Ian this thing's beautiful
fact I wanted
well so a yeah it's a little cursed
unfortunately that's not a stake
uh
yeah wow that is
that is the most cursed item we've come
across today
in fact the Cosby doll is Crying In Fear
right now
and unfortunately this is like legally
binding you have to take this
um yeah and it is attached to yourself
the guy didn't give a lot of details he
said he just sort of it just sort of
like showed up so you found it on
Craigslist yes and did you pay for it
yes okay so he's already like wow how
much you pay for this thing
uh 50 bucks
can I give you the fifth oh you know the
budget was a little higher this year so
we went away I'll give you a hundred
dollars no it's actually there's good
things read it read someone want to buy
this I'm not taking this home read what
it says
it doesn't work like that sorry that's
not how it works it doesn't work like
how it works read read read read
it's it doesn't work like that love love
Pride honesty and loyalty
[Applause]
yeah it's a crucified demon with a
[ __ ] uh baby burrowing out of it from
love peace and unity bro can I trade you
for the steak please unfortunately
actually the steak that's gonna go to
Lena
foreign
[Applause]
well hold on I I'm not done breaking
this down dude I have more questions so
you paid someone 50 bucks for this oh my
God it cut me oh [ __ ] oh yeah
oh [ __ ]
oh no I put the mic up to the cut like
it's gonna say so
yo um so you went so what did he look
like who was he he sort of had like a
sailor aesthetic okay sailor yeah like
you've seen some [ __ ]
like what yeah yeah yeah
um did he ask you anything like why
not really I think he there was a sense
of relief I think right and I I don't
know why really
um well what's interesting Zach is that
you chose it yes which is part of the
book binds the curse he had a shot he
really
he blew that one all right well you'll
take that back to your seat Zach
I suppose
[Music]
I'm just gonna leave it here
what are we gonna call it yeah no this
thing's dude this thing's rock and roll
yeah put it up at the troubadour
we'll just make a pile here congrats
Zach
there you go
yeah congratulations Zach that thing is
rock and roll as [ __ ] I don't know
gotta make some wall room Chantal gonna
make some wall room on that one over the
bed
[Music]
now that's a good idea yeah
welcome
I'm thinking over the bed Zach what are
you feeling about that that's beautiful
maybe on the roof over the bed yeah
well congratulations Zach uh Merry
Christmas to you you're very welcome
you're very welcome and so I guess
oh by the way I should say that Jimmy
was so God I'm already look at this dude
I've already got like a weird red bump
there on my wrist from the curse
scratching me you see that blood of the
Lamb
oh my God by the blood of the Lamb
so I guess yeah Jimmy was supposed to
fly out yes we're gonna put him in a
Christmas Box we had a whole plan bust
out you had no idea I had no idea we he
had agreed he said yes I'll be there we
had like way too many phone calls like
too many
uh I I gave him I'm sorry Jimmy I gave
him a burner phone number and he added
me to like eight group chats with all
these numbers I've never seen before
that's classic Jimmy
um but wait you didn't call Steve Rossi
I think he was in there yeah Jimmy has
for my number I gave him Cameron's
number he messaged me a couple a couple
weeks ago he's like I I can't do it I'm
gonna check if Jimmy's texting me right
now he probably is yeah yeah all right
anyway Lena so Lena let's go ahead and
bust it too you want to pop that open
this is a bit of a two-parter can I ask
you something yeah what if Zach picked
the rectangular one would Lena get the
curse why I was very confident because
Zach uh is very cursed dude I can't that
was a so there's that's messed up
no surprises
it's actually a Sizzler steak oh my God
take it out man
a side of toast
oh she got her own present I'd like to
like
[Music]
baby oh what the [ __ ] dude
why wait why'd you do that
it almost killed me the last time I had
it well so a b it's not cursed this is
all thought through my friend Amy why
are you throwing steak around bro
coming coming from the guy who just
threw chicken at people while he's sick
yeah it's memorabilia dude
oh this thing don't look right
what's the camera also it's not hello so
shame come take a look at this Hue on
this steak man we're gonna need that by
the way so don't throw it oh we do need
this we will be get a look at that Hue
that ain't look right yeah just just get
the juice right that's not good that's
not it I think this might be the cursed
item Zach
yeah that thing looks green man what's
wrong with it all right so this is a
two-parter so if you want to pop this
open Lena see a b you might need this
steak actually maybe keep the sugar hold
on to this
hold on this wasn't planned was it how
did you know Zach was gonna pick that
all right
this is for me this is for you yes
what it's a Navy [ __ ] doll
now if you turn that around
oh my God
so this is called a choking Charlie oh
no and you use it to CPR train oh my God
so you put a little bit of food in the
mouth and then you hit the chest and
it'll pop right out so I figured you
guys might need this
yeah they might actually save my life
that could be life-changing yeah that
would work take a little piece of that
shove it shove it in his hole there
[Laughter]
you might be choking a little bit that
might be
now just you guys like that lift the
lift the shirt lift the shirt up so you
can really see uh
oh whoa
steamy Steve
so right on that stomach there you want
to slam that right there yeah just hit
it oh there he goes
there we go
we might have just saved a life tonight
does that feel like the real thing Lena
yeah
you're very welcome how are you feeling
about that AB with that uh is that is
his throat is tight and [ __ ] as
babies
looks like it yeah nice
nice
are you gonna have some fun later my
friend
yep
well that's a really thoughtful gift
actually yes yes thank you guys thank
you may have saved my life so yes I
appreciate it thank you do we still need
this because it really smells good I was
gonna ask can I throw it now yeah well
no dude
[Applause]
oh my God
who wants one of these
all right I don't want to hit someone
that don't want it all right there I see
you I see you that's so good
don't eat that
[Music]
just so you know
we do not make the FDA does not certify
Us in any way for food safety I'm making
meat smoking these weeds here do not eat
it
know your way around some meat
all right
Craigslist is off to a magical start yes
yes and so I guess after this we will go
to a b now uh let me let me get this set
up for a second hold on I gotta hand you
something first
so excited
it's a shame uh how are you feeling
because you went to the doctor and they
said there's nothing wrong with your
throat so is that I I feel like I wasted
300 and uh you scared the [ __ ] out of me
but I'm glad I got it checked but I
really miss that 300.
you missed the money
all right
so here's this why don't first first
maybe pop that open and then we have a
special video
show
it's very thin
is what she said
[Music]
I set myself up for my own stuff okay
[Applause]
what do we got 20.
wow
wow hold on
all right hold on okay okay it's not
hold on now
Instagram ad credit but first Dan can we
roll This video
and happy Christmas an H3 podcast and an
even happier Christmas to you A B
yes this video is for a b he's a very
special guy I love him every member of
the H3 podcast loves him and the
audience loves him and as someone who is
loved and adored he deserves a very
special gift so we've all teamed up and
we've gotten you this 100
authentic idubbbz photo so this is no
ordinary photo this is a photo that you
can use on all things
and not only that we've loaded up your
account with twenty dollars in ad credit
don't [ __ ] it up
right now
[Applause]
get on your phone and start uh checking
out all the Impressions that you're
getting whether we follows likes shares
uh and you know don't pay attention to
like the geographic location where
they're coming from that's not important
it doesn't matter if they're in
Bangladesh or in Cambodia they're real
people okay it is not it's still people
there's still people yes okay so thank
you a B for being an awesome guy and
thank you to the H3 podcast for keeping
it real yeah
salaam alaikum
Salama like them what
he says
he's learning Arabic it's very good oh
yeah because he's really good yeah and
he says the same mix as me Lebanese
Irish yeah show up congratulations baby
obviously uh you were running and out of
you and Ian on on Instagram and we
wanted to legitimize it so thank you
thank you appreciate can we get up can
we get that photo to Dan so we can pull
it up I just want to see what it looks
like
yeah send that to Dan and then we can
get the ad running for you right now
ASAP you know I I like it but I already
kind of have an ad with him maybe next
time another YouTuber perhaps uh you
know just switch it up I I love you know
I love you guys
don't push come on
who better than not no I'm kidding yeah
Casey neistat you think I could pull
that you got me a Casey video Once
star
I'm I'm collecting them all blacks I got
keemstar
yeah
did you send that photo to Dan Ian yeah
I'll send it uh Sam had to yeah congrats
AB thank you guys yeah we're gonna run
that
yes we'll get that up right away me and
idubbbz were talking we were wondering
we're like man it'd be fun if we just
put like 50 000 ad spend on this so
[ __ ] everybody on the internet side
me good man uh who's next I don't have
my phone so up next on this magical
Craig's Miss Eve uh we have none other
than the Beautiful
the One of a Kind the love of my life
Zach Bernstein I'm kidding Eva
Ela Klein yes
all right
okay
what a magical evening huh
another thin one
okay so don't open it just yet hold on
one sec so this one I I was I found
something that was fine it wasn't great
if if Dan Dan actually should have the
picture of what I originally found and I
wasn't excited
sorry my disk my Discord audio is on
guys
that's crazy it's like super loud watch
this yo thank God it wasn't me oh okay
that Discord audio let's see how do I
how do I mute this [ __ ] Dan I'm [ __ ]
boom
you want me to do it dad can you run up
here and mute my laptop it's all good
it's all good you can do it from there I
am happy
there's Dad
is hacking into the Mainframe
it's not your fault all right so here's
here's the picture
all right all right all right all right
so go go ahead Ian I originally saw this
poster it's fine you know you got really
the Mount Rushmore here
Joe Rogan Trump Andrew Tate Elon Musk
Jordan Peterson and Tristan Tate the
alpha poster for 15 everything I'm not
yeah it's um it just wasn't good enough
I I felt like so we we took it a step
farther if you want to pop that open now
oh my God we had to take it a little a
little what could it be
that's the game whoa
whoa
wow
all my heroes
why why yes just towering Above the Rest
there
um CEO Sigma grind said oh [ __ ] you okay
did you shake your head no he's good you
okay
two thumbs up if you're okay what
happened nod your head if you're okay
oh he's cursed now
um
dude that's awesome
to kill them like what's the situation
here
I
I think yeah what well see they're all
they're all doing a cheers
um yeah you probably put like arsenic in
there or something I don't know
or not you definitely didn't do that um
we put wet in their teeth in Minecraft
listen in
please oh my God you come to my live
show
talking about pushing arsenic
It's My Life shows
if anybody's gonna make a death threat
it's me
[Applause]
listen Ian
I'm gonna take you out on the lake show
you what a death threat is
all right cut it cut it Zach we don't
need that live
thank you Ian yes you're welcome that's
awesome I will definitely keep this the
the great thinkers of Our Generation yes
yeah
wow wow wow I'm just at a loss for words
that's a beautiful gift thank you uh
congrats uh Ela
Dan did you get the photo of uh AV I
really want to see it
uh Ian did you send it to me
[Music]
he's slacking oh let's we're playing
send it to me
yeah so up next
um
is the
he's the dreamer of Dreams
he is
the man who makes who dreams it and
wills it
his name starts with a C
and ends with Emily
foreign
[Applause]
is very nice Cameron is very nice
little package doesn't look weird so
this might be one of my favorites I've
ever found on Craigslist so for this one
um first we need to see the ad the
Craigslist ad
on this
um there should be Gallery Mr Dan
okay
my soul
free and clear conscience for 12 million
dollars what so I don't know if we
should read all of this it's a lot
One Soul precise spiritual age unknown
but reputed to be from Atlantis he says
as I have no use for it one preferred to
live the remainder of my days with some
semblance of dignity and not homeless up
for bid is one soul my own to the
highest bidder what physical Earth ages
53 for precise spiritual age is unknown
I've never quite understood the
attraction or uh comprehend why certain
collectors of souls grow their way to
acquire them but if someone finds value
in it I'm happy to part ways with mine
for the right price although this soul
is not perfect it's certainly won a very
high value the soul currently does not
hold any curses
you hear that didn't say nor is it
cursed by others it has not committed
any crimes nor felonies committing to
wrongdoings which will cause it to be
penalized in a later date aside from
some white lies and a few other less
than consequential misdemeanors the soul
is Rock Solid plus it is bilingual as it
speaks French and English this soul is
reportedly kind joyous loving giving
creative and sweet although I don't
think Souls have a gender or a gender
preference the Soul's owner was a gay
male in the physical form here on Earth
as well it is from a Jewish origin
maternal side with the mother of this
Soul arriving to the US from Poland she
was a polish jew whose father spent 18
months at Auschwitz living under Nazi
control there's a long history to the
soul there's a lot
um and uh let's see so as Jew I really
have no use for it in the afterlife
because we do not enjoy The Spoils of
one anyway so let this Soul go to
someone who needs it I can use the money
for my physical time left on Earth and
let the new owner use it for the
afterlife dude
[Applause]
this is the sweetest gift I've ever
gotten how did you know I've always hold
on you didn't open it yeah hold on uh-oh
now can you pull up the post again my
favorite part that was like 12 million
12 million my favorite part posted 24
days ago nobody picked that [ __ ] up
I guess the price is a little steep
though now there's there's a couple of
more images in that Gallery there's this
um a second image because obviously it's
Craig's Craigslist we do not have the
budget so it's all your listing
regarding the soul unfortunately the
price is a bit far out of my budget as
I'll be giving this Soul as a secret
Santa gift could you do 20 bucks
you're haggling for a soul dude yeah
unfortunately it's a little tight so I
have one more photo there I went to a
Chipotle in North Hollywood
and there it is
wow there it is oh my God open open it
up so hold on you got it you got him
down to 20 bucks yes so Kim if you want
to read the certificate
dude I've always wanted a gay Atlantis
polish soul from
Jewish too yeah Jewish welcome to the
family well let me read this uh that was
that was the person that was him looks
like a regular
legit
person who sold this was now wait does
that mean you have to kill him what's he
doing today but does he have to die no I
think I think he needs to die I don't
think so I have to die he's just quite
nice
wait hold on hold on with the soul does
the soul only activate when he dies
all right so this certificate of
ownership reads as follows this is the
certified that Cameron Grant that's me
uh is hereby the rightful and proud
owner of 83 out of 5 millionth of the
soul of Mr Philip n so I only own a part
of the soul for 20 bucks you're gonna
get eight thirds of five millionth peace
uh and shall enjoy this day forward all
the rights and privileges according such
ownership delivered freely and without
reservation on this day the 15th of
December 2022 signed with the scribble
wow
so wow thank you very much this is the
sweetest gift I've ever gotten on
Christmas shout out Phillip Phillip n
for that shout out Philippine so what
was the fraction there of the Soul you
got there
83 out of 5 million I'm I'm on my way to
getting a full Soul it's a tiny little
you're in the Parks per million yeah
I'll get there eventually yeah he was
very adamant when I met him he was like
yeah I'm Jewish like I don't need it is
that who's got a point you you gave me a
little uh priest backstory too that you
were you were warned ahead of time to be
careful of whoever the [ __ ] thought it
was a little weird yeah he he was like
it's sort of like giving um a big
beautiful steak dinner to a vegan that's
how that's what he described it he's
like why would I need this Soul so give
it to someone who wants it so is this
like uh cryptocurrency kinda but it's
like you could mint it yeah yeah soul
coin cool so this guy was for real
yeah that's that's legit oh my God and
um
that's awesome man thank you very much
so we don't need to kill him
I think so for 83rd five million when I
get to 5 million you can kill me Ethan
yeah I'm not gonna kill you oh I'm not
killing anybody I'm not killing anyone
yeah for that small piece maybe he needs
to it's not gonna do it like a hangnail
or something I don't know I tell you
I'll tell you who I do want to kill hey
we're going on break if you're gonna do
this wait till we get back so we get
some more time please the audience with
my great jokes yeah
right with my fantastic sense of humor
I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna
bomb this whole building
yes
with my great sense of humor I'll tell
you what no not the b word the technical
difficulty screen I'd like to take a
walk through Vatican City if you know
what I mean
what I said a walk
I just said a walk in big trouble hey
Ian who's uh next on Craigslist how is
Dan doing I mean
um up next is uh well uh
I'm getting a little bashful but it's
it's me
[Applause]
uh
so yours is
n't for one right in the center here
this big tall tall one right there
uh it's a little heavy so maybe we could
wheel it over here
foreign
it's pretty heavy huh
standing the base
is it a
a harp
[Music]
okay
thank you wow I'm so excited thank you
Ian
feels wiry yeah it's a big heavy
all right do you have a guess of what it
might be
[Music]
jerky
that's right
there's no better guess than that all
right let's just open it oh man that's a
dangerous that's a sharp end right there
dude
okay
is that the mother
is that Lady Liberty herself
for this free speech Warrior Ethan Klein
oh my god wow
[Music]
finally someone that understands me Ian
I am
the greatest
Free Speech Warrior this one this
thing's heavy bro
oh [ __ ] I've ever seen
and it's also got a menu for some reason
why does it have a menu you know it's
because it's from a Red Robin Red Robin
America there's nothing more American
than Red Robin boy this is the Burger of
Liberty
I tell you what man ain't nothing more
American than a red robin
wow get a close-up of that face huh what
happened to that face so there's there's
a photo
kill me
there's a photo Dan if you can show
because I said to Sam can you try and
make it look like this
[Applause]
whoa
wait what
wait this has been altered
oh my God I see no difference
wait what get bring the camera back so
they can see
Christmas in July
[Music]
it's America
that's America
that's America
that's America to me
come on
come on wow that's beautiful thank you
guys
very welcome wow
movies
yeah the next time
somebody accused me of being awoke
anti-free speech activist you sent him
this picture yeah
and you tell them what's up it's my girl
right here up yours whoop more or less
[ __ ] you Jordan Peterson
sorry Ela sorry baby I'm married to
Mother Liberty now
it's so
[Music]
your burger was there okay I didn't do
that it came like I didn't realize it's
a hamburger wait did y'all see this I
bring the bring them away you just saw
it
how do you know there was so much to
take in
I was just so much to see and that's can
we plug it in it's not really work it's
covered in like glue and coffee
I really want to take this off yeah
thank you all right wait there's a
hammer up here
that's the lie I don't know it's bright
I've got [ __ ] I didn't get a babysitter
tonight and I've got a fever
I'm really tired it's been a long week
up yours
Twitter's a [ __ ] Rat Hole
[Applause]
thank you bud I appreciate that you're
welcome
oh oh my God I got this
[Applause]
all right
oh my God
oh we're really gonna do that
you have your passports did you get your
shots girl would you like to come back
to America
[Music]
[Applause]
America
did you have your passports did you get
your shots girl would you like to come
back with Rob to America
oh yes I know come on baby get them
shots girl
sit down
do you have your passports did you get
your shots
[Music]
[Applause]
to America
to America
thank you baby thank you meet me after
the show
[Applause]
man that's
still blows my mind actually
[Music]
man R Kelly
does she get conjugal visits
um
what what
about Allah died
yeah level time
[Applause]
EB did that yeah what happened everyone
saw that
wasn't me I don't know I probably lost
internet connection don't worry Amy what
did you do
I literally wasn't even over here
thank God bro I saw you how are you
still talking oh you run wait we can
hear love okay he's still here oh Love's
still here yeah in fact yo
[ __ ] building
we got him some upgrades
guys in the front row
just so you know
this if this Falls you will be impaled
and died
can someone help me with this so I don't
want to die
I prefer for someone not to die
if possible
it's a preference
[Applause]
dad can you keep me DPI gang did you
follow the DPI
no Zach don't do it Zach
from 200 DPI oh my God it's so loud
Jesus
you know what Dan it's out of your hands
now Zach's got the sound bite [ __ ] you
Dad
800 DPI
you no longer monopolize the DPI Dan
congrats keeping him down for too long
play it Zach
8200 DPI
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right I feel like I'm being cheated
on right now sorry Dan yeah it's with me
now Dan get used to it [ __ ] you Zack
oh I got the photo can you pull it up
this is actually really nice uh photo a
b here pull that up Dan
yeah one sec nothing's gonna beat them
yeah we got we got the official present
uh we were able to develop the photo and
we're actually running it on Instagram
right now
Dan is going to pull that up
high tech
there it is
that's official bro you know what I mean
at least now people will know
that it's officially sanctioned yeah
I feel Vindicated thank you yeah I guess
I did something to push off the
Instagram Gods so congrats buddy thank
you I'm I'm most jealous of that one man
that's big well uh
[Music]
the audience is impressed with Olivia's
makeup as usual
oh wait did you guys see Ila's makeup
today
[Applause]
thank you oh it's so rude
hey you guys got us to leave the house
how about that
fever
what the view damn all right well
Goddamn dude it's like dude we're gonna
be at like 2 A.M about this
[Applause]
what time are they kicking us out of
here I think midnight so what are they
gonna do make us leave this train yeah
baby I've got a question I've got a
question what are they gonna do about it
[Applause]
right
there
call the police yeah
anything else cool they're gonna do
all right
yeah we got to keep it moving okay so up
next is um Olivia Olivia Olivia Olivia
[Applause]
yeah
there's this big one sort of towering
behind the ELA over here now I would say
go stand behind her and
um I'll give a little back story on this
so this one
um I reached out the owner she was like
this really sweet like 85 year old woman
and she was like a few weeks ago have
you ever heard of this guy Jimmy Kimmel
uh she was like Jimmy kimball
called me and wanted me to bring this to
be on his show but I didn't want to
drive and I don't have a license so that
was it and she was like I didn't want to
do it and uh so I I took it and this
thing might be one of the most cursed
things ever
so was this the really expensive one
year no no this wasn't that bad how much
was this one I was we'll talk about it
later okay but this so go be very
careful this is very delicate very
delicate so do we need to bring it up
front did she need a hand I think it's
good
Olivia is a huge fan of Hamilton Musical
she loves it
so we wanted to get her something to
commemorate
wow what the [ __ ]
yo what is that
hey you want to trade
yo what the [ __ ]
he died
so wait is that supposed to be Hamilton
this is this is Hamilton the legend oh
he's handsome oh yeah
[Applause]
paper mache that's awesome made by hand
his geta looks kind of close up of his
hands if you could I mean those things
yeah yeah
[Applause]
nice I think you got it you should you
should you should see the back of his
head because it came like this
um
yeah
and so he sheds a lot it's just a hair
clip yeah he's disintegrating
oh my God
[Laughter]
Hey Olivia I'll gladly trade you
why does his hands look like he [ __ ]
died of like
right that too he has great shoes though
he has great shoes really yes yes so we
beat Jimmy Kimmel on this one huh we did
Jimmy Kimble suck it [ __ ] you Jimmy
hey guys I have some breaking news Ethan
you just got on banned from Twitter
really stay here what yeah get on banned
from Twitter
hold on hold on
it's true
what did my dick come out or something
I think he said you're unbanned from
Twitter wait are you serious yes
really yes wait how do you guys know
that
I'm on your Twitter right now dude
[Music]
there it is
[Applause]
wait hold on first thing I need to do
change your name I need to change my
name
because okay this wait it says I have 65
followers
wait what look behind you
get the get that away from me
wait it's restarted my follower account
I think it's going to repopulate It's
Gonna Come Back
what the [ __ ] elong ma would never do
this to me what about mine
but do you guys see that it says I have
200 followers
it's gonna come back I think
what is a [ __ ] Rat Hole
you know my such a little [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] hater is insane
[ __ ] Elon Musk [ __ ] Elon Musk [ __ ] Elon
Musk [ __ ] Elon Musk
hey uh it does appear go ahead
check it out
well you know my first tweet back's got
to be back to you get to you look at the
screen guys hold on let me change I'm
just gonna change my name to Elon oh
mine is back too yes ma'am okay hold on
sir I may change my name right now to
Elon I have one follower
I gotta change it to Elon Musk um and
then uh Elon Musk CEO
of Twitter yeah yeah yeah yeah I gotta
put it back far enough so people don't
see it CEO of Twitter
and Tesla and then in parentheses parody
so it's far back so people don't see it
but there's a raffle
oh it says I can't okay wait
can you not change your name I'm trying
it says I can't put Twitter in my name
like excuse me what [ __ ] rat hold the
girls is this
okay here we go Elon musio Tesla parody
let's do our first tweet let's do a
video
of the audience
[Applause]
[ __ ]
you Elon musky sword
[Applause]
okay we gotta redo that I'll just get a
little bit
what a great Audience by the way
whenever the light goes on I'm like damn
some really cool people here yo what did
Elon tweet can you pull it up Dan
[Music]
yeah we're doing a little bit we just do
a little fomo out here
wait what can you pull up his tweet Dan
this is breaking news all different
flavors different Believers it knew that
flavor so
he says flavor like Santa's little elf
all different flavors flavors
flavors that's a man that loves flavors
you know what I mean
believers
okay wait this is big news Dan did you
could you pull up the [ __ ] year that
you didn't tweet
you know what I mean
oh pull up the video that we made with
PNP too I want to show the
let's go let's go Dan are you copying
that
are you copying all that down nope what
were you saying sorry
all right first can you pull up Elon
Musk tweet yeah
[Music]
um
give to you
yeah are you everyone
are you on that Dan this is a whole show
of just like inside jokes
could listen to this and understand it
wait when did it I'm just confused
Dan are you
are you hearing okay W Dan are you
listening
[Applause]
Wayne okay here we go
where did he announce that he was
unbanning everybody
how did you guys know yeah how did you
guys know
people from Shots
love you friend out how'd you find out
people from shot just kept spamming it
oh it just happened yeah it just
happened you know when I went on my
homepage it said welcome back did you
see that Ela they're like okay Elon
welcome back I had 2.3 million followers
now I have a well I have 1800.
you'll get there buddy and and Rising
[ __ ] okay now the first thing
um can you paste me the one about um
at Jeffrey Epstein being his best friend
I just want to post that again now that
I'm back
it says parody and it's not funny all
right ninja shut up
yes so um anyway sorry derail oh yeah
pull up the PNP video real fast
speaking of Twitter I want to show you
guys this you guys are gonna like this
let's go
thank you
all right everyone on right side of
court with my great client here
um and his case was messed up he was
falsely accused of being extremely
impaired on multiple substances in fact
he had a drug-induced psychosis totally
lost his mind while driving on the
freeway crashed into multiple cars they
all flipped over and ignited into flames
exploded actually once he miraculously
got out because the fire department used
the jaws of life he started fighting the
fire department fighting the police he
even went up to a random car and
allegedly pulled them out and beat the
crap out of them and look they're trying
to throw the book at him in court but
I'm pleased to announce that we got
involved with a dry Reckless ride
thriving which will come off his record
in one year after we expunging how you
feeling I feel great Dave is the best uh
let's go
[Applause]
it's dry and Reckless just the way I
like to get down
dry all right
don't worry if we ever get through this
like I said I hope you all got
listen guys
[ __ ] hell we've already been going
two hours Jesus really we barely yeah it
is
okay we did Olivia congratulations uh
Olivia Olivia yes there you go and
finally our our present here for
oh boy so wait dan one second I'm here
there's a little context maybe just play
like 45 seconds of the video there okay
and then come on down let me load this
up
just just a little taste it doesn't bro
I'm not eating that [ __ ] that's that's a
bull penis dog you have to it's why are
you obsessed with eating dick and balls
bro okay why why are we watching this
just you'll find out soon enough so do I
just watch Dan don't ask do we need to
see more maybe just a little taste why
not okay what do you like what are you
obsessing dick and balls bro I like them
raw in a different again like supports
like you know again that's why the
tissue is called what it is yeah it's
sauce man
that looks super
tender but the thing is it's it's not
just dick and balls right you're just
gonna Force us raw dick right now we're
about to eat raw yo take me out for
dinner first man I guess you are
technically take me on a date today okay
that's good just just a visual so come
on down Dan and I've got a special Box
come on down Dan right here for you join
us on stage my friend
this is the big moment
down
damn damn damn
damn damn
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the big one come on Dan take a
seat
you've earned it you've earned it my
friend
[Music]
you just go for it just go for it
[Music]
it's in a box
[Music]
now we like to call Dan Dan the wizard
on the show because he's
I mean he's a star really you can do it
all I can do it all
and what does every wizard need what
does every wizard need
a staff Ah that's an interesting
every wizard needs a staff
[Music]
all right so yeah I should just pop that
open there
no mountain is too high no C 2D
and no stop raised it up in the air like
the wizard you are
kid
what yes
raise it up high
oh my God
[Applause]
so so am I correct in assuming this is
the bull penis uh embedded in resin I'm
not no I'm not [ __ ] touching that bro
I can't get a nice shot of this camera
yeah yeah that my friends
is a bull penis
[Music]
handed staff Dan take a walk around the
stage for us please
put your hand on that glorious bull [ __ ]
[Music]
hold it by the dick it's it's
great do it
[Music]
yeah
it's still squishy even in the resin I
swear to God that's horrible
can you can you give us a strut give us
a strut if you would please
no no no no you gotta hold the [ __ ] in
your hands right side thank you
yes
he was born to yell and wield it
how's it smell can I touch I'm gonna
feel it
yeah that's pretty squishy but also
surprisingly firm
congrats bro
what an honor
[Music]
ah
that's actually what I walked in on Sam
making by the way oh my God
joke that was Sam's magnum opus I think
it's my best work I really do I walked
in
[Applause]
I walked in on Sam
she was on the floor with a tiny little
uh fan like what and like a bucket with
like a tooth or [ __ ] I can't think
straight anymore
it was a needle and fishing line because
I had to like pierce it and then dunk it
in the resin over and over and it was
hanging to dry so oh my God
yeah beautiful work hard
I'm just glad we used it because that
was in the office at work for like two
months I feel like after the episode or
a month right we got something out of it
Ethan asked us to throw that away and I
was like yeah yeah
well I was getting sick of seeing it in
the [ __ ] fridge every day like yolk
had kept it in there it was like a jar
of pickles or something
I moved it to the other fridge she never
knew yeah
Teddy fresh has been asked what's the
deal with this oh my God it was in their
fridge yeah yeah oh my God that's got to
be an HR issue dude you know we have HR
on Teddy fresh
oh my God we're gonna get sued by the
city for that one for sure anyways
that's it that's uh that's Craigslist
that's awesome
yeah thank you Ian well done Merry
Christmas to everybody uh it's a Time
held family tradition here in the
History Podcast and we're just so
thrilled and honored so thank you Ian
thank you Sam and on that note I gotta
pee
all right
yeah I do want to
I do want to say if uh you can pull up
the tweet I just want to show you guys
something real fast you go to my Twitter
and then we'll move on to the next
segment but this is important
here's the tweet in question
five minutes what is
pride mean
even though uh Jeffrey Epstein committed
horrible crimes I do still miss him on
nights like this for his warmth and
camaraderie
rest in peace old friend
yes
yes
gone but not forgotten
all right moving on here um we got to
keep things moving so up next well here
I'll be honest with you guys
this is kind of tradition as anything I
gotta go to the bathroom I gotta pee
so I'm gonna run out I'm just gonna go
I'll be right back and I'm gonna hand it
off to um how bad you have to pee right
now I might have it off to Ethan here
here you go
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
it's great to see all my adoring fans
out here love you guys
uh you know you guys really bring a joy
to my heart
uh
so um so what's going on everybody hi
hey oh my lovely wife here I almost I
didn't see you there oh my God
how did you feel the kids are great uh
what are their names
um
what are your children's names what do
you think
uh Pauline
um
[Applause]
I'm a little out of it today uh yeah why
huh
yeah yeah I've been sick I've been sick
lately so
you know I'm trying to trying to keep my
spirits up or you know around the
holidays and
have you just been spending home oh yeah
I'm at home with your great cheesecake
backstage so that's been going great
um
do you know what's her name
oh yeah this is uh this is Sam uh
of course of course I know my own crew
okay okay these are my homies I know I
know everybody over here
what are what are our names
Rachel yeah
incredible
uh Samantha yes
[Applause]
there's two Sams huh makes sense all
right right two cents uh this is
hey Ethan uh now that this is on stage
and you're on camera and everything
could I get a raise Ethan yeah I will
give you wait what do you make currently
Let's do let's just double it you know
you know what I make I'll triple it
triple it thank you you've done a camera
you've done a wonderful job
triple salary for Matt
what's that triple salary for Matt
exactly thank you very much boss you're
welcome
anybody else anybody have any questions
our names me and this gentleman yeah I I
have a question I have this pain in my
right yeah yeah
um do you know anything about medical
work or like WebMD medical
um I would say if you have a pain in
your ear it might be like a tumor or
something okay
Okay so
probably just drink a lot of alcohol
alcohol so you can dump the pain okay
okay yeah thank you
no I can count no problem I want to take
care of you
I want you to know you can rely on me
oh that's so sweet Ethan how are you how
are you feeling
I feel great thank you thank you for
asking me how I feel sure sure I gotta
gotta take care of the um marital needs
so I want to be a supportive husband
and uh
look what looks like that's it for me
[Applause]
uh who's this guy this is not
y'all aren't supposed to be what is this
who the [ __ ] are you what what who the
[ __ ] are you get out of my seat
bro
yeah what
you guys you guys know me right did you
guys see
no Barry this isn't anything you just
are you boy is this padded are you
trying to say some [ __ ] this guy's sure
you're wearing a padded suit huh
I look more like come on let's get it
it's not real you don't kiss me it's not
real you don't want this I'm sick all
right all right Ethan thank you bro
you're the best man okay um
yes so my parents are having dinner
later tonight so you just gotta make
sure not to be late on that oh yeah sure
and then tomorrow morning
um Eli's family's in town you're gonna
get breakfast with them all right cool
cool yeah just send me there's a meeting
yeah well we have a shared calendar but
there's a meeting next week with um
one of our agencies but you'll be able
to meet that you'll be there on Tuesday
at 12. uh I yeah I think I can make it
in oh come on you gotta wait for your
schedule this whole thing you're going
to be there
okay I'll I'll let you know bro come on
all right I'll pencil it in Ethan
there's also uh the hike with Philly D
on Thursday oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um tomorrow morning
uh there's the hike with Philly D you'll
be there oh [ __ ] I forgot about that
yeah yeah thanks bro okay I'll be there
thank you can you hide don't take my mic
man [ __ ]
all right
oh
so glad I could
pee and not miss anything
so nice all right let's move it all
along here uh up next
this man I'd introduce him if he needed
one but he really doesn't welcome to
this show The One and Only America's
favorite attorney
[Music]
let's go let's go let's go
starts with let's ends with gold let's
go
thank you
let's go
they love you
David
looking Dapper my friend
thank you
you come from port or you dress up just
for the show
well at a long day I got the deposition
and mediation PMP did really well for
the people today really
let's go and you know I was in court the
other day and a prosecutor told me you
know what uh
my daughter is going to that H3 show so
I want to give a shout out to an Amanda
oh my God Amanda your dad's gonna give
me a good deal because of this damn yeah
thanks to you Amanda a [ __ ] like
serial drunk driver is back on the road
let's go he only
David yeah yo trust me if y'all get a
drunk driving it don't matter if you
kill like a whole family people he'll
get you wet and Reckless
just like our boy Ryan Kavanaugh so
here's what I wanted to ask you actually
I had a legal question for you
um let me pull up
yeah no socks thank you it was a
Hanukkah present
[Applause]
uh this card on the rails here otherwise
they're gonna call the fire department
now what
[Music]
hopefully P can get me out of whatever
legal Jeopardy comes from fighting with
the fire department okay so as you guys
know we've been showing
um our guests a video of a prolapse
[Applause]
yeah
yeah I know I know I know
you're gonna show me it hold on hold on
guys you don't know what I'm gonna say
now listen I wanna walk out wait Ethan
we talked about this what do we do about
it well okay my question is there's like
a minute clip of a really graphic video
of
cumin prolapsing hold on hold on hold on
hold on this is important
and then I said I said can I legally
show this to the audience
now I thought
I thought that we sold the tickets as a
18 plus show but I think it was all ages
[Laughter]
Dan no no I don't see anyone under 18
can you hit the lights on the audience
yeah I don't see any kids
it's probably not the best way to do it
don't play that okay hold on
that's not a good attack
which one of you no no no no no what's
to come home with me no no no no no
[Applause]
and you
you you you you
I caught it
so if anyone's under 18 can you raise
your hand
okay I saw some hands okay
all right first of all you know when
you're asking the audience that you
already [ __ ] up yes it's already bad
[ __ ] up but so okay so
here's to my question
PNP David if you will
can I show the video to the audience now
before you answer
Dan roll the video
not up to prolapse but of the reactions
oh okay yeah that I can do just to
refresh
huh
get some places
[Applause]
oh that's making me [ __ ] gag [ __ ]
I love hunger
what the [ __ ] why is she [ __ ] up
okay
yeah so obviously not an exaggeration
no you want to show them this video
I want to show everyone that video yeah
what's the matter you have ever seen two
dude go prolapse or prolapse much
approves
[Applause]
you know what hold on everybody I gotta
say this that is the first time at any
show people have chanted together
prolapse and I just want everyone to
recognize it world first
prolapse
God damn all right so
David come here I want to show you the
video and then you can tell
make sure you can get a good shot of
David's face camera people
yeah so whenever you're ready
only Ethan can make prolapses great
again
should I do should I use the audio or
not what do you think no no no no no no
no
all right okay go ahead yeah I'll play
the audio actually [ __ ] it all right
and I've seen some crazy [ __ ] oh no you
have not
[Applause]
[Applause]
let's go
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this way how long is this yeah
it's so crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
how did they go to the bathroom
yeah so
that's a lot right
yeah Ethan you know what
what is your legal advice
I came up out here inclined to tell you
to show everyone
that video but
yeah
all right look
[Applause]
well hold on I need my my uh the advice
for my attorney because I do not want to
get on a sex offender list for showing
this video look it's not worth it
it's out here right yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] up as that is and I see [ __ ] up
[ __ ] on the daily
that was
top five [ __ ] up [ __ ] I've ever
[ __ ] seen and this man talked about
jaw life
and as much as I want you to show
everyone so that they can have the
reaction I had
that's a Surefire way to get on the sex
offender registration right
oh yeah well I was getting worried
because backstage I was talking to and
and you're like there's not necessarily
anything wrong with it I was like are
you sure that was before you showed me
it that was okay that wasn't just a
prolapse they were getting like sexual
with it oh yeah that was legitimate like
prolax porn yeah yeah and Sam there was
a lot of talk about your
you are unbothered Sam please
times I've had to look at prolapses at
this job I'm completely desensitized
right
W Sam
Wham dude everyone was freaking the [ __ ]
out and Sam looked like she just seen a
sunrise
all right it is kind of fascinating now
can I ask you this if we sell our next
show 18 plus could we show it
I think so
I think so
you think so because I don't want to
take any risks maybe 21 points maybe
we'll do some homework
um
I'm like 99 sure you can at 18 plus yeah
and what's the one percent you're
worried about just curious
with the law you just don't know what
you don't know
but
a lot like
there's probably a prolapse carve out in
Texas or some [ __ ]
it's like one of those things they'd
actually like the U.S and in House of
Representatives will put out a statute
making this retroactively illegal once
you do it right
[Applause]
sorry guys I I don't think of people are
can I post it to my newly unbanned
Twitter account
[Applause]
I think I would get banned all right
next time next time guys
Twitter's a rat hole Yeah listen you
guys gotta come to the next show if you
want to see the prolapse a little bit of
a selling opportunity
it'll be worth it thank you David
appreciate that for your legal advice of
course and uh anyone have anyone have
any legal questions for David real fast
I'll field one anyone been drunk driving
uh blessing
um domestic abuse what do you got that
guy over there looks like he's uh been
through some [ __ ] recently you've been
through some [ __ ]
what do you got this guy's got some
he hit a parked car
was there anyone in there
did you run away
you run him over a mic he he says
he's on it here we're gonna run him over
a mic real quick thanks he said he says
he hit a park car
there was no one in the car but security
which was trying to get him to stay
until I got that right alleged all
Legend thank you allegedly all right so
when security allegedly stopped you
we're even the act of trying to run away
I offered them some money if I could
just leave oh
it's pretty slick
what do you think David like hey but
they said no how much you offer him I
offered them 20 each
and they said no so I waited for the guy
and gave him 100 instead
oh and he was cool with it so these
episodes no legal issue yeah you're all
good yeah you're all good wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
I
let's go I didn't have a license at the
time oh
well don't hold on hold on allegedly
now you're [ __ ] you were fine now
you're [ __ ] did this happen in Los
Angeles
um
Riverside County oh you're [ __ ]
prison oh my God the police are outside
right now
all right thanks David appreciate you
buddy we got to keep it rolling thank
you
let's go
let's go let's go
thanks bro
this is our real life saw Goodman I'll
give a [ __ ] David is more Saul Goodman
than Saul Goodman everyone hell yeah
let's go you know what I mean thank you
baby
all right we'll move it along oh what
happened did you just jump up that was
hot was that hot oh he jumped up what's
up I didn't miss did you hop up real
easy or something was that hot you guys
oh my God
you guys are easy
because they're easy my fat assity oh
you look at me you're like [ __ ] he could
go he could climb up a three foot wall
he's so hot
it's not easy
[ __ ] wait what's up with the lights
uh I'm not sure hold on we're having
some some issues here
whoa what's going on
wait
[Music]
cursed enough wait what's with the
lights
can you all fix that or is that like a
technical issue
everything seems fine on our side I I
think it's more of a spiritual issue
we're having oh no what do we do about
it
um
am I supposed to just do okay do you
like
oh wait
oh my God
[Applause]
just the person we needed
hi everyone
Linda the Ghost Hunter
so I've been thinking about you guys I
don't know what you got into the
spiritual realm but you've been in my
mind so I don't know what's happening
what happened
okay well
hold on are the lights
I thought Gabe was supposed to kill the
lights down we wrote it so that the Gabe
curse kills the lights because I had a
bit planned for when Gabe curse kills
the lights okay do you want to just
pretend that none of that happened and
we'll take it again kill the light yeah
Linda can you go yeah yeah you want me
go back okay
yeah Linda
yeah let's just do take two
wait oh god what happened
to the light oh I don't know oh there
doesn't seem to be anything wrong on the
tech side right maybe this is a spirit
if only somebody had the brightest
flashlight
ever made
if only somebody had a flashlight that
went to six thousand lumens
and had a fan installed wait okay [ __ ] I
don't know how to stop it
six billion lumens
there it is
[Music]
don't shine it at the audience oh [ __ ]
sorry wait let me okay if only somebody
out of light was 600 000 lumens
[Music]
[Applause]
and his eye the Hall's teeth and dude
it's so [ __ ] hot under this [ __ ]
okay
Linda are you here
[Music]
[Applause]
Linda the Ghost Hunter
who could have seen this coming
I had no idea surprise surprise Linda so
we have been having an issue okay we
have a friend of the show white claw
game
he invited us all to his birthday party
I do
well ever so he invited us all to his
birthday party
and we all said we would go and I'm
sorry to say that we didn't none of us
went zero not only all zero not even one
yeah no it's Maine it's rude
I know [ __ ] up we [ __ ] up
we [ __ ] up well I had an excuse
because I didn't have a babysitter and
it was a long day
you know I hadn't a good excuse but a
lot of these a lot I never said I was
going I just want to throw that out
there I've never I never confirmed I
said I would go if anyone else went all
right no excuses
the fact of the matter is the currency
is here and ever since we
trying to get the flashlight on ever
since we missed
there's been a curse upon us and
terrible things have been happening yeah
I'm hearing the audience whisper Amy's
dick babies did a B for example snapped
his dick in half
wow
are you okay AB by the way is it all
fully healed I think so you think so
improve it
show us your dick
[Applause]
Lena can he show us his dick
he's saying she's saying no
she's usually pretty cool but she's not
down with that
I'll tell you whatever you want to know
no not that of course is he okay is his
dick okay yeah okay yeah oh she seems
happy with it real quick Ethan as much
as the spooky flashlight gag is uh funny
um you can't see anything on the stage
like at all well here guys cover well
here what about now
isn't exactly what I had in mind maybe
we could just just
maybe we can just bring out the lights
yeah bring the lights back this thing's
actually too hot to hold all right sorry
everybody I'm not liable if you get
permanent damage
let's go
game
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks buddy you can hold that hold that
have a seat next to Linda please
yeah no he'll sit next he'll sit next to
Linda
[Applause]
all right
so so Linda yes the ghost hunter that is
me
this is White Cloud Gabe who we canceled
on his party and tons of things been
happening bad and we just need to know
once and for all how to lift
this white clock gave a curse wow may I
add all of us
in Sweden which makes can't explain that
it makes no sense and we all have the
same symptoms including love in Sweden
it's Gabe and this all came from you
[ __ ] yeah baby
okay that's a yes okay well luckily
luckily
I brought some stuff that should help
okay okay please okay
okay so I didn't bring my usual gear
because we're not
we're not we're dealing with
a terrible like would you say you hex
them or it's a curse you put a curse on
them
oh boy okay so all that show up we're
dealing with a girl first
oh okay you got curves you're willing to
work with Linda to lift it right sure
yeah
okay
so first we're going to start with this
little device I don't know if you guys
can hear this
so what this does it takes negative
energy and turns it into positive energy
so we're going to start with some
positive energy that's a great way to
start lifting a curse okay and so
people have been using this for years
[Music]
to get rid of curses
yeah you got this okay so this is we're
going to have to Sage all of you because
we're gonna have to I've never get rid
of this negative energy so we're going
to keep this running okay but what are
we going to do who's in Sweden how are
we going to help
um Love is don't worry about him okay
all right okay he'll be fine okay yeah
okay
[Applause]
he's good I'm I'm reciting him right now
so okay we'll try and Sage you in Sweden
I don't know if it's gonna work or not
love what's going on in your forehead
you like tuck the hairs out or something
it's his hair
sorry I got distracted by Love's
beautiful hair
[Music]
okay so we got the sage burning
could smell it out there yeah everybody
can smell it yeah just come come please
I'm just gonna like smudge you guys
that's what I'm gonna do so it smells
like weed it does so let's take all the
negative curse
a positive energy the negative is gone
the positive is good okay
negative gone positive good
no more anyone getting hurt bro I gotta
come over there wait let me get Sam I
gotta get Sam okay
here we go okay we got it we gotta
smudge you we gotta needs extra yes okay
we got especially you we gotta do a
double dose on you I know
actually Hamilton needs some too oh we
got to go to Hamilton and go get
Hamilton
sorry Hamilton there we go Hamilton I
don't know how to help you dude you're
looking pretty bad but yeah we'll do the
best we can we're just gonna smudge you
and try not to put you on fire that all
right that's the best we can do
okay and then
verbally just
just try and release this curse we have
to talk about not doing curses in the
future okay sure okay all right let's
not do that
so what now
love
out with the bad and with the good okay
tongues I don't know maybe it helps okay
so I want everybody just to on this
stage and the audience we can really use
your help on this because we're dealing
with obviously a pretty serious curse
everybody got sick so what we what we
right now is maybe broke his dick in
half just to because that's horrible I'm
so sorry I'm so sorry terrible terrible
situation thank you Linda so if we could
just having sex in the shower and he
dismounted oh wow wow in a really weird
way wow this is the only
okay so one more little quiet step here
if we can just all everyone on the stage
let's just just close our eyes for a
second and we're gonna visualize that we
actually went to this birthday party
okay
and that we had a great time and this
curse yeah bring down the lights let's
really let's really do this yeah we had
a really good time we had some cocktails
we enjoyed ourselves everyone really
enjoyed we gave good presents that's it
we need those Woos we need those Woos
and because we all went to this party I
asked all the Spirit guides who are with
me to
release the curse of my friends here at
H3 okay guys please release this curse I
need you all to repeat after me okay
[ __ ] my ass
[ __ ] on my tits
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
everybody come on this is serious say it
again
oh no back one suck my dick [ __ ] that
one suck my dick [ __ ]
and then what about [ __ ] in my ass baby
or whatever shut up my ass baby
[Music]
okay and then do this one
[ __ ] on my
[ __ ] on my toes and then put it back in
my your butt and then [ __ ] it back in my
butt [ __ ]
shutting my toes can't put it back in my
butt [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I gotta release it thanks bro happy New
Year happy 20th we had a healthy year
best wishes God bless you baby happy
2023 be expect me back yeah [ __ ]
White Club game everybody in Class Act
release the curse release the curse
release the curse happened 2023 [ __ ]
[Applause]
well thank you Game
thanks brother where'd this might come
from it's yours all right all right we
have too many likes who's Mike hey hold
on okay wait I now have three mics
[Music]
okay somebody take those microphones
away
okay I got four mics take the mics away
[Music]
[Applause]
wait there's some interference happening
wait I think I have too many of my gods
oh [ __ ] okay
he doesn't get none
of this one
bad things happen when Dan's not
within arm's length
okay do you feel that the negative
energies have been absorbed
I feel like honestly when I walked out
here this isn't my usual H3 let's have
fun let's chase some ghosts felt a lot
of negative energy around you guys I
really did but guess what I feel the
light I feel the love and I think
they're back yeah
Linda
do me a favor
stand up and I think to finally dispel
this give the audience please a [ __ ]
baby [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] baby [ __ ] yo
it's lifted thank you Linda well here do
I do are you comfortable hugging a sick
person yeah
she's like she's like I [ __ ] with spirit
s off germs hell no
[Applause]
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] yeah
thank you Linda
the Ghost Hunter ladies and gentlemen
one and only
[Applause]
[Music]
dude we need a poltergeist reboot where
she's like
the only or well she's not she's this
analogy is not going to be flattering
I'm gonna stop right now
I love Linda I see excuse me hey you
were able to stop a joke
I know I'm getting better at it
[Applause]
someone say call me queen
[Laughter]
who called me queen
put your hand up I want to know who did
it all right guys up next
I made a promise
it got me in some hot water I said come
Christmas time I'm gonna get Jesus back
on the cross and I'm gonna smear him
again
and all you heathens clapped and laughed
[Applause]
[Music]
well
today I make good on that promise
bring out Jesus
[Applause]
Jesus
[Applause]
hey dude
you were like yo Hassan do you want to
do the live show with me
[Applause]
lies I was gonna be wearing this yeah
yeah no no no don't worry what is that
what so this is a cross
oh yeah we didn't tell you what this was
[Applause]
okay okay I was I did not sign up for
this what the [ __ ] wait do we have the
spears uh spikes and and Hammer so we're
gonna we're just gonna mock crucify you
no
what do you mean no amen okay first of
all I'm Muslim this is the you guys
thing like Jews creatures you guys deal
with that
ah we're done we have spikes hurry okay
we have the before he changes
because I stole the sound bite is that
what happened
oh
all right I've never felt more exposed
in my entire life I was trying to turn
it around you look good in that thing
man I was trying to
do me a favor do me a favor what's up
turn around tuck it will you tuck it in
your ass for us oh
no okay I tried I tried I I tried
sitting down just give us one of these
[Applause]
I could smell it
my man all right so we brought yeah we
brought you out to do the mock cross
crucifixion of Jesus but so you're not
down no
I didn't understand why I was wearing
this to begin with and then and then
this came out I mean I I feel a little
bit betrayed by Ian you guys didn't tell
him we were gonna crucify him crack up
[Applause]
say it you can say it can I cracker
shout out to Susan bajiki win on Twitch
[ __ ] we can say cracker
you're a cracker
you're gonna get bam watch out
maybe don't push it
um all right so what are we gonna do
then
I mean I don't know it's your show
they want us to kiss
[Applause]
well you want me to sit down
yeah I wanna I feel so
I wanted to send some they want us to
kiss but I I know this is good no no no
am I I'm sick I don't know if I'm hiding
enough it's enough
oh thank you be careful
I've already seen Cameron's we need a
modesty blanket for his son
Jesus was a bit of a [ __ ] he was dick
out
bro I heard Jesus had a hog he's over
here sitting like Bradley Martin on the
show show yeah I don't think I've ever
shown this much leg
ever
so special so Hassan uh since we're not
going to crucify you and desecrate the
memory of Jesus Christ here on
I thought I thought okay that she is
literally trying to she was upstairs
delete that video she upskirted me the
front row tickets are getting a show
yeah
she said she saw your dick oh my God I
hope you liked it
foreign
they want us to kiss but um
it's not that's it oh yeah he's sick
we'll do it leftovers next season
you mean when we come back yeah when we
come back yeah one time better we'll
kiss
yeah he's sick
yeah he had 103 degree fever
all right what I thought we would do
instead because you're being a [ __ ] oh
you won't let us [ __ ] nail you to the
Cross I'm sorry my bad and I thought we
could make fun of the quartering at
least oh yeah
okay
because because Jeremy from the
quartering has been
begging Elon to make him the CEO of
Twitter which is probably the saddest
[ __ ] thing I've ever seen did you see
his video he came out with a video where
he was in the middle of the night he was
like I woke up in a panic and I made
this video I'm sacrificing my algorithm
for this one
yeah let's pull it can you pull up some
of those damage I lifted the sanction on
the quartering on my stream for this
because
it's uniquely pathetic
so even for a man who peed in his own
basement yeah yeah I heard he's shedding
it yeah [ __ ] my basement uh there's
about like 30 tweets so some of these
maybe out of order or deleted I couldn't
find the order of all of them so
um the fact that people are confident
enough to be Fielding their Twitter CEO
applications to Elon says it all like
they're like yeah and and you know what
they're probably right that Elon is just
gonna pick some random [ __ ] on yeah yeah
he made policy changes because of what
quarter pounder was saying like quarter
pounder literally was like I have a link
tree Elon and Elon was like that's a
good idea actually my bad yeah he so
this all started when when Elon
responded to the quartering and it set
him off on some [ __ ] love love potion
frenzy he said hey Elon Musa that I get
accounts whose sole purpose is to
promote other big accounts forbidden I
what did I read that right
it didn't make sense when I read it let
me try again which one are you reading
hey Elon Musk
I get accounts whose sole purpose to
promote other accounts being forbidden
but telling people they can't link out
to their Instagram is way too far the
same goes for linktree I use mine to
link to my website my coffee Biz not to
compete with Twitter and then this was
the tweet that Elon Musk said okay that
seems reasonable
like it wasn't [ __ ] obvious to him I
mean
I mean he only has the best Consultants
every time I turned on Twitter Elon Musk
is like responding to another crypto guy
who's like telling him the most obvious
[ __ ] reminding him why they already have
these rules set in place it's great you
get that crotch rot yeah
that's on his application I believe
crotch rot I'm very glad to hear this
quartering says thank you for always
being open to feedback and then at the
frenzy begins all CB we adjust policy
will be adjusted suspend accounts only
when that accounts primary purpose is
promotion of competitors which
essentially falls under the no spam
thank you sir
I saved the Lane Tree quartering
pronounces
please enjoy a delicious cup of coffee
tea or cocoa
come on give the people what they want
[Applause]
Adolf Hitler dude
[Applause]
that's the sentence had a lot of good
ideas I'd never said that nope he
invented the uh microphone
the microphones that we're using right
now we don't have our parody oh yeah
[Music]
um
Hitler
um yeah so then this is when it gets
really sad Elon puts up this poll and
says should I uh step down his head of
Twitter I will abide by the results he
got body slammed 57 yes
is that awesome did you do you think he
expected people to say
yeah no I think he already he already
got wrapped up with some you know some
Saudi people that are backing him in
Qatar when he was at the World Cup
because he was there with Jared Kushner
too and Eric Kushner yeah he's gonna be
running running Twitter next I think
that'll be great
so you you think he knew he was going to
get ousted via Twitter poll yeah I think
he just wanted to go out in the most
lame way possible he wanted like
plausible deniability yeah that he
didn't quit like a little baby I saw
people saying that he was already being
told that he's got to step down oh for
sure I mean just this past week the
Tesla stock has taken a nosedive which
was expected you know and
he's been he's been tweeting on the job
Non-Stop and obviously I'm no fan of
CEOs I don't think they do a lot of you
know I don't think they bring along
excuse me except for you guys you guys
are great sitting next to one yeah but I
mean anyone who's ever worked a job
knows like you have to fake it you can't
constantly be tweeting on the job
because your boss is gonna you know
they're gonna walk past you'll be like
what the [ __ ] are you doing like
everyone knows you have to pull up the
Excel spreadshe you start acting like
you're pulling numbers in there you know
what I mean when your manager is walking
by but Elon is so out of touch that he
does not even realize that so now his
investors are like publicly shaming him
and being like dude get off the [ __ ]
Bird app and get back to work at Tesla
right now the stock is tanking and now
he's just duking it out with them
publicly
it's insane Amen brother that's right
here's quartering now it gets real sad
hit me with some real sad
[Music]
the quartering says hit me with some sad
music Zach
please
don't step down
but maybe add some help
I think your gut is Right Far More Than
it's wrong
stuff on stuff
but you need a nice little Inner Circle
like a board of advisors
there's so much potential on Twitter
I just think it's hard to prioritize
right now
he continues so insightful
I'm like fine he reaches out to Mr B's
Jim who's the best part
he's hysterical no Mr Beast no
it's called out Elon Elon policy change
in the links and when you lose Mr B's
it's over dude if you don't know Mr
Beast is like a huge Elon scene oh yeah
he he was in his replies Deep In The Cut
fighting with him I mean uh defending
him when everyone was like oh this guy
sucks I think that he really
personal level I think that really hurt
Elon when he saw that quartering goes
Jimmy it hurt me to see two guys that
love each other so deeply fight like
that it's not right I hate to see it
Jimmy please DM me
I can explain
he already reversed course and this is
the most important poll in history
we need to keep Elon as CEO
if I could just get three minutes on the
phone with you Elon Musk
I could convince him to stay a little
longer
please share the video above we cannot
lose this vote
I really I really thought the dude who
pissed in his basement could not debase
himself any further publicly until this
it's pretty incredible did you hear
about his story [ __ ] in the target
is the best place to [ __ ] in a Walmart
on a trip with his wife go ahead eat
Zach just run it like the diarrhea down
his leg a lot of bowel movements around
his wife this is weird
Zach's in The Matrix I'm [ __ ] my
pants shit's coming out of my down my
leg is that there's [ __ ] all over the
floor
[ __ ] my basement
yep
if you don't if you don't vote no on
this poll you don't care about Free
Speech you don't care about the Public
Square
this is everything
Elon Musk and he added him I know you
want to step down and I fully expect it
but this is way too early you need more
time to shift the culture than a few
weeks
look I'm 40. I'm tired I'm sweaty I'm
fat I'm overweight
that has from his Elon video wait what
that's from his Elon video I watched it
it's the first and last video I will
ever watch when he said that about
himself yeah as part of his application
no he was like he's because he wanted to
make it seemed like it was sacrificing
so much by posting is he writing a note
to his doctor or application in BC or
Play It Again Zach look I'm 40. I'm
tired I'm sweating I'm fat I'm
overweight make that guy CEO
he said he doesn't have long for this
world too I was like
oh that's [ __ ] awesome
bro come on man
at the end of the day that's a lot of
tweets here bro we don't have that much
time so there's 15 more holy [ __ ] dude
it was going on and on I do want to call
attention to this one where he spelled
pole p-o-l-e
um I think at this point in the night he
was pretty hammered like I'm pretty
confident yeah and on his CV would you
put pissing and [ __ ] in my basement
drain at the top or bottom of the CV or
maybe the intro letter
cover letter
there it is though
all right so any chance of getting you
on that cross or not no I'm just trying
to butter you up
you're like let's talk a little let's
talk a little politics and then I'll
nail you to the cross I won't really
impale you just to be clear
still no all right
Hassan Pike for everybody
thank you everybody
[Music]
thanks bro
[Music]
thanks bro
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
assault biker classic
I try to get him to show ass I tried him
getting show dick but he was smarter he
fooled us he brought a modesty blanket
she actually works for me the upskirt
girl
should we throw this I feel like it has
some value
all right all right
[Music]
whose blanket is this I just bought it
oh all right
[Applause]
who wants his son's blanket with Bubba
ganous smell
[Applause]
someone just got elbowed in the head
all right smell it okay smell it does it
smell you smell [ __ ]
nice you smell good strong
how dare I what'd I do
I should have sold that [ __ ] thing I
hope that's worth getting sick because
we've been sitting on it all day
joke's on you all right so anyway uh
thank you Hassan beautiful
[Music]
what a guy all right so now we're moving
on actually we're doing okay on time we
caught up a little bit right Dan uh
we're doing okay
um
so it's 11 o'clock technically we got to
be wrapping it up by 11 30 if we go over
a little bit we're going down
what are they gonna do uh well they're
gonna charge us money they're gonna
charge us how much uh money
let's negotiate let's talk money and
we only have uh one big segment left and
and then our uh you're in review video I
think goodbye so if we just blast
through it I think we're good yeah I
think we're good actually so so
um last year
we made predictions at the very end of
the year yes you some of you may
remember
um and we took bets we all bet each
other
and we would see who came out on top now
we have an award called the Nostra
dumbass award
to award the winner let's go over our
very own
Nostra dumbass award
[Music]
she is beautiful he is great
he is Mr
Nostradamus all right sorry all right
cut the music
all right we're in a hurry I can't be
riffing on
those are dumbass bees
all right so coming up from the top here
the first bet we had at the end of last
year was will there be a new covid
variant
a big one right like because the last
one was Omi omnicron
and I actually
[Music]
I actually positioned that this was the
last one right and y'all should have
listened because I'm like the covid
soothsayer like I've been calling this
[ __ ] from day one with the kovid and you
guys may be surprised every single one
of y'all took me on that bat Dan
said no a b Zach in Gila why'd I call
you Hilo this person
[Music]
love they all said no I said yes I have
I think I took the dub on that one right
yeah omnicron was it
and aren't we happy
[ __ ] covid
covet ass [ __ ]
[Applause]
how was that as far as um
pandemics go was that a good one or like
I don't know it's like a I'd say C tier
dude well like what's s like black
plague yeah yeah oh yeah it's probably a
F2 or maybe maybe I don't want a million
people die that's pretty good numbers
B no it's not B it's more like a d tier
does somebody know is this covet related
we did get that Tick Tock out of it that
makes it easy right now yeah yeah that's
okay
um the next one was just super sick
we're all like we made it out of there
we're all like half dying yeah that's
true we made it three fever
Ian lost his [ __ ] taste for the whole
year right
Joe Rogan gets dropped by Spotify
[Music]
Ela said yes I said no Dan said No Love
said no ELA that did not happen
good guess though at the time he was
under a lot of heat it seemed possible
yeah
but they were in a lot of guacamole
right so we're gonna be on that the
queen dies
[Applause]
yo y'all are [ __ ] up
y'all are sick twisted [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so countless dude we literally just tap
dance on her grave
oh that's funny it's funny
it's funny
Ian he's very upset right now
you okay
yeah you didn't come home mom well that
was actually Dan proposition he said and
Dan did you have inside info on that
because you said the queen will die and
I mean she was bullish here's the thing
I thought that she already was secretly
dead when we made it up and then they
were just covering it up which still may
be true uh to be honest so what are they
covering up if she's dead well they were
preparing like they knew like they
weren't quite ready to announce it
because she disappeared for a while yeah
she was like out of the public eye for a
good amount of time and then when they
did show ER was like from like really
far away like it could just be somebody
in like a costume or something I think
she like thought it went out of hell
like Kratos that time yeah for a little
bit the Doom guy yeah
um sweet Lizzy in a box
we didn't make like a toy like
Jack-in-the-Box lives in a box
foreign
there's so many fun games you can play
with the queen stuff
such a light topic to joke about okay
does Zach get a Rolex
show it off
and he got it
[Music]
thank you
I got it
I gotta be honest Zack
I didn't think you were again because I
thought I was the only one who's gonna
buy you that Rolex
because I said I'm not buying it from
this year so I said no
and uh but wait I said yet I'm I'm the
only person that thought he would get it
besides himself you're a good man thanks
baby love you buddy
but that's but congrats man that's thank
you that's a huge move you got it
has it changed things for you do you
feel like newer do you fresher I feel uh
different
katari Qatari
I feel uh
gay red hair
I feel to just hit me with the fousey
come on you've only played it once today
just for the record Zach doesn't have
his normal setup right now
he does not no he does not yeah so I
mean he has more sound bite but I I felt
gay I felt that note like that just
based on what they told me I am a Muslim
I am Jewish I am black I am gay today I
feel uh gay
[Applause]
oh I now play the quartering I felt
overweight I felt tired I felt look I'm
40. I'm tired I'm sweaty I'm fat I'm
overweight it's kind of it's hitting the
same note yeah
without a doubt yeah was it listening to
our show and like subconsciously
that's such a good guess because you
know he's a fan we love you Jeremy yeah
we love Jeremy we do
that makes sense
up next this was a weird one Richard
Simmons will make a comeback I don't
know what the [ __ ] that one was
[Applause]
there was a lot of action on that one
from Zach
I don't even know what like what is that
even that's ex-girlfriend insurance but
he did not come back right I don't know
he did that's incorrect Ethan we defined
it very clearly he said that Richard
Simmons who Zach what he had been off
the grid for several years at that point
about a decade for about a decade he had
been off the grid that Richard Simmons
would make a comeback he would make some
sort of social media posts and I regret
to inform you if you could punch this up
on the screen thank you very much
Richard Simmons did in fact make a
Facebook post
I love you this is the weirdest [ __ ]
prediction ever and somehow Zach got it
right so I don't even know what to say
either
all right either Richard Simmons is a
fan of the show
or this is some q a [ __ ] signal to
the Troops
Richard Simmons is q for sure Richard
Simmons we all love you we want you to
come back
[Music]
we got this straight from 1995 Emoji
pack hey give him a little credit you
know he hasn't really been on social
media a lot
okay here's Ryan Kavanaugh files another
lawsuit against Ethan
um or or the roast who we love
love Wikipedia um that did not happen no
thank you only four only the four
teen-year-old Natalie Portman
Ryan Kavanaugh look it up guys has he
paid your legal fees yet no no no he
hasn't
it [ __ ] right Kavanaugh [ __ ] Brian
Cavanaugh
[ __ ] Brian Kavanaugh [ __ ] Ryan Cavanaugh
[ __ ] Ryan Cavanaugh [ __ ] Ryan Cavanaugh
thank you okay there's one
there's one other breed
there's one other person too much wine
[ __ ] Oliver tree [ __ ] Oliver tree [ __ ]
all of her trees [ __ ] Oliver trees
that sucks dude what the [ __ ]
oh this one up next kind of stings but
uh Amy wins his boxing match
hmm you had a heart you had next year
hey I'm I'm happy with it I'm hearing
there's no poll it was a question
Dan it's a bad pole I'm getting bad
there's no ball there's not even a pole
um I sorry I voted that you would lose
and I'm and I'm so sorry but I did I was
right it was my main motivation yeah but
you your heart the heart I knocked his
ass down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we thought he would die
that's my wife that's my own wife yeah
he survived he didn't die no he did not
die remember when we first saw the
photos of his opponent and we're like oh
my God yeah oh yeah it was a beast Brett
waited until we all went to Vegas to
release that photo it was our we
literally just got to Vegas all of us
and then he released a photo of him
looking like the [ __ ] right smashing
through the door yeah yeah personally I
thought
they called the call was rigged as [ __ ]
bro I was with you it was a bad call it
was a bad poll
but I'll tell you what this year it's
going to be a whole different story for
ab
[Applause]
s yeah I'm I'm I'm I'm fighting someone
bigger than hondur so no you're not they
are
yo [ __ ] that guy they're bigger than
hondard
why I think I just have to pay baby no
no I'm not gonna spoil I know I almost
leaked some never mind okay
a uh a b only lost because Ethan you
voted when you were losing he's the true
sample of the show he had to do that for
your predictions thank you yes this one
was kind of funny
we voted would I get strikes this year
what was would we go a year with no
strikes I said yes
Dan however had other thoughts
I was the only one that took that bet
and I said uh no that's not happening
sorry to say I was right well there was
a very new dish uh judicial year for us
here on YouTube judicial
they came down hard on us
G Lane Maxwell [ __ ] dies
she's still ticking surprising you know
she's still going strong free G Lane am
I right
just me okay
no I'd say Freer I say let her out
no
sorry never mind you're speaking as you
as your Twitter Elon parody account
um so the final results of last year's
read it from
first
the worst okay can you unblock it for me
Dan and that sounded wrong can you make
it visible to me
on Highlights thank you and last
although we love her I don't know how
this is possible Ela came in at negative
two
yeah he was in debt oh my God
he lives in Nostradamus debt which means
I think you're the smartest
um love came in
uh sixth place with four points
hey that's pretty good
Ian came in fifth place with seven
a b came in fourth place with eight
Zach
came in third place with nine
damn came in second seventeen
and you're no straight dumbass 2000 is
it 21 or 22 22.
is Ethan with 27 points
he's Mr Nostradamus
thank you my dunce ball
my crystal ball tell me the secrets of
2023
thank you wow
well
thank you everybody that what an honor I
think I took it down on the covid one
y'all really got cleaned up on that one
but I'm happy here to say that now at
the bottom of our show here
I know I'm sorry but we still got a
little bit left here
excuse me
all right well here's our predictions
our list I'll just read them off and
then we can go to vote love moves to the
U.S
feeling good about that one Zach shits
himself
you know if we don't hurry this up man I
might happen
well hold on it's not even 2023 yet
Chantal said why
we're gonna we're gonna mail
we're gonna put mayo and Dan's Dome
because I got below 200 pounds
let's do it let's get it Ethan let's get
it I'm feeling that
I actually think Dan should mail up that
Dome
[Music]
I am feeling good about that uh me and
Hassan will kiss
Ethan hikes with Philly D that's not
happening
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah I wonder if
I wonder if we should just look at the
poll results that everyone voted on yeah
that'd be because I'm otherwise I'm
going to end up reading it through it
twice
well so love moves to the U.S got 87 of
the audience vote so they're confident
uh feeling good yeah feeling good thank
you guys uh Zach shoots his pants uh 47
of the audience okay you 47 said yes or
wait oh no 52 said they that you would
yeah I love you all
hey 50
that's they said You're Gonna Keep Your
Shorts clean and that's pretty good
we'll see what happens seems like a
toss-up yeah
uh Ethan gets below 200 pounds 86
percent said uh yes
love you guys
thank you guys Hassan and Ethan kiss 89
saying yes
the other 11 percentage just hate
jealous haters
Ethan hikes with Philly D 59 said no
it ain't happening
Twitter I mean I mean Ethan look alike
will heck with him every morning if he
wants
Twitter goes bankrupt 65 said yes
the podcast gets another strike 91 of
the audience come on oh man that's sad
[ __ ] I gotta do better well you know
we're getting the kill switch next year
right now
that's right did we order it already is
like in the mail type of thing that
works it's in the works that's good I'm
gonna need that uh Zach books Coachella
2024.
uh 48 said yes
pretty good
that's a good odds
[Music]
uh Trump is arrested 64 said no oh
[Music]
uh Joe Biden enters a vegetative state
or afterlife 46 said yes wow Joe Biden
vegetative state anyone
I love hairy legs I'm jumping on my legs
now just to be clear
Joe Biden is to enter a vegetative state
I did not have anything to do with it
yeah no Wally said it Wally said it two
years it was Wally very soon don't even
know everybody it's Wally sorry love
sorry Joe Biden very soon you go to hell
it was him
uh Prince Charles goes in a box like
Lizzy ooh 60 said yes
old sausage fingers so you think he's
gonna die this year
it's not even that old you guys are
ruthless to the poor English
uh there's some sort of Kanye slash
Ethan crossover 58 said no
crossover I think is like a mention of
Ethan or some sort of acknowledgment of
each other I think
well that is interesting because his
homie Nick Fuentes is definitely on the
Ethan pipeline kids loved Hitler and as
you know kids love Hitler
I love Now history
oh we got to get Kanye to say that
H3 H3
uh Ethan is sued again 56 said yes come
on
the last thing I need
Amy wins his creator clutch fights 74
said yes
thank you thank you thank you very sweet
I'm on your side this time I'm voting
yes I'm not on my side this time no you
got it you're gonna kill him dude you're
gonna kill him yeah you're gonna kill
him I'll try but not like button like
Minecraft right knowing who the guy is
Abby's got this like he's got this I'm
very confident yeah the other guy said
let's go yeah that's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude
this is the most dumbest like
full yes I've seen so far Dan uses the
live delay switch that saves the podcast
95
yes wow yeah wow
we need that live switch yesterday W Dan
Robinson gets married 78 said no
sorry Olivia how you feeling Olivia I
mean they said no yeah I know but just
checking in on the Pete Davidson dating
he's with is he with uh Emma well you
know what what's your name both were
seen on dates with other people
so I think they're both dating around
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so maybe they're just casually looking
up
that's good so there's still there's
still a chance maybe
that's right I will say there was like a
spot for people to put in their own and
I saw a good amount of people saying
Olivia will meet Pete Davidson this year
so a lot of confidence there I like that
idea
uh Ninja apologizes to Pokemon 82 said
no
not happening
[ __ ] that dude
yo
you know it um
fortnite Balenciaga you know ninja be
doing 360 no scopes on those [ __ ]
guard towers y'all know he would be
good he'd be good he'd be scooping goo
out of the chambers
he'd be like he'd be like with a shovel
oh I can't control my Google
I can't control my goo
I think he's all on my nose is [ __ ]
massive just saying
oh we forgive him
all right keep me on the rails please
somebody take control he's almost made
it through
77 said yes
man I still want to slice of that dobric
that might be cold before I get a slice
no you're saying no
H3 Pizza that'd be sound slap I
guarantee you
but you might experience you might get
the flu if you eat it
uh Jimmy Lee on Jimmy Kimmel I'm gonna
read the positive version 22 said yes
wow I feel like we can make that happen
uh yeah bro I don't [ __ ] know man
Zach you also said you're playing at
Coachella next year so wasn't this thing
supposed to be ooh spikes no I'm not
talking [ __ ] I'm just saying he's a
dreamer
so
Zach do you want to unpack.com
Let It Ride man
he thought he he dreamed he get a Rolex
he got it I believe in him Olivia I'm
gonna I'm gonna be the better person
here and I'll let you have that I'll let
you have though I'm not saying it's not
possible I believe in you
put me down for his action to play
all right can we move on please
Olivia pointed out that the Jeff or the
Hamilton was meant to be on Jimmy Kimmel
right maybe we could dress up Jimmy
let's put Jimmy Lee inside the Hamilton
and [ __ ] send them if they still need
him and then hey don't push
fomo horse out
uh Drake faces a major cancellation 57
said yes really interesting
okay hold on that's more than five
that's way more than five
uh Elon snaps and gets caught jerking
off Coney 2012 style this was a neat
that was me I like that 48 said yes dude
Elon is for sure going 20 21 or 2012.
about the 2012 all over this match
what tough crowd sorry 21. [ __ ] you
uh lecture and whatever keep going uh
who uses a nuke 71 uh no
30 yes pretty much
the second amendment protects your right
to own nuclear weapons moving on from
that one uh significant evidence of
alien life is discovered 50 uh six
percent said yes yeah
Tesla completely tanks 56 says yes
the final one
We snuck it in there the final one Ethan
insisted first of all you said it was
suggestion I said let the people out
there highly suggested so Ethan said
Ethan and Trisha make up
55 said yes wow optimistic crowd
it takes that five percent
[Applause]
fifty five percent five percent it's not
55 percent
that's funny
well there it is [ __ ] I don't know man
you all predicted it let's see what
happens I you know what I mean
[Music]
thank you guys for participating that
was fun appreciate it
oh God don't answer that I don't think
we're taking questions no questions
please she asked how do you feel about
that making up you listed no questions
at this time don't push
you guys really want a pride minute a
live Pride minute
are we set up for a live Pride minute
Dan
and then we'll do the year in review
let's do it it's just one minute
Dan let me know when you start what
could one minute mean
it's too long if you ask me
all them gays
all right I have the stopwatch ready
let's begin Prime minute right now yeah
so listen everybody who feels a little
bit good
stand up
let's get those hands in the air okay
lgbtq kings and queens and everything in
between
we're all in one big closet together
today boy
[Music]
it's good to be gay you don't got to be
ashamed so who's good who is gay
everybody
today I feel gay
gay friend that probably wants to [ __ ]
you like that just be yourself man [ __ ]
the world doesn't matter
[Music]
popping the gay out
you know what I mean just feel it don't
let anybody tell you who you are or who
to love to keep our countries oh you are
born to be gay okay
I'm not gay no more
lights off lights off
[ __ ] you
now repent
now repent back in the closet
how do you think you are I got a picture
of everyone who's standing up
it was a trap
I'm sending them to uh
what's his name the [ __ ] uh yeah I'm
sending him to the pope he'll do he'll
take care of y'all
maybe you change now
in Jesus
and shame on you I'll tell you what man
then floods come down on you Jesus
there's some earthquakes down down up
north from I saw a man sucking a dick
out there in San Francisco and I said I
shall quaint the Earth alone
[Music]
what the hell do you think you are
oh
I said be gone
Sinners you're not God
I watch
the man I watched as a man finished on
another man's hand
and at the moment he finished the
earthquake struck the land
come to join us and together we'll end
women
and we can't be having that money now
I'll repent
please in the name of God now I know you
all be thinking that the same gender be
looking nice and scrumptious at times
amen amen but you gotta fight them
demons boy
I believe it because when death touch
other dick why doesn't the demons come
out to death
from Death to life damn right
[Applause]
Lord no repent
I wish you all could see that prolapse
to prolapse I'll tell you what I heard
when prolapse go prolapse
goddamn Hiroshima the Sun
all right we got a rep there thank you
thank you for the cross all right
thank you
yeah listen guys next year the minutes
pushing it we're good we've talked to I
think it's gonna be Pride half minute
next year just to curb your expectations
you know Jordan Peterson says it's it's
too long a whole month
all right guys we coming out to the
bottom of our show here it's 11 30. I
feel like I'm close to dying
anyway we prepared can't not we Cameron
hey that's me
hey as they're working his buns off
on a 2022 year in review and we have
quite a year to review we've all been
through a lot and I just want to say
well let's watch the video and then I'll
give my little Spiel so go ahead Dan
whenever you're ready run that
[Music]
well well well welcome back everybody
okay there's someone you've all been
missing they've got long blonde hair
they disgust me Oliver tree
looks like you uh you haven't really
been taking care of yourself
[Music]
all right
thank you
it's crazy bro
here's the thing
um never talk about my wife in this
contest oh okay oh my God is that for me
yeah maybe mark my words I will put this
up on my screen his name is love that's
not a cool name
[Music]
[Applause]
guys
that's disgusting are we cooking Hassan
we had our son born baby Bruce beautiful
babies
I forget that you gave birth and they
say he's a mini
[Applause]
microphone
my beautiful girlfriend Allison
we don't have enough time
I love her we live together and we have
to uh we have two wonderful dogs Ian and
Sam of course fantastic met on the beach
Thriller the bachelor with the H3 I'll
never forget the beige Thriller my
following is all the girls in the gays
and the days the Holy Trinity today I
feel uh gay I am gay I felt gay I felt
that no like that just based on what
they told me
whatever it is just be proud of yourself
man you know nobody can tell you who you
are all right time's up I'm not gay no
more
[Music]
[Music]
America
he's here
[Applause]
[Applause]
Little Brian
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dumbest should I ever seen that's why
I'm all in I lost a financial
sponsorship as a result of that video
going live
and that is one swatched beef my friend
and then do you forgive me for saying
that working out is a waste of time I
will represent the gym Community we
should we should forgive you think I
exercised and I forgive you for lying
about uh Steve jerking off his dog
[Music]
dip your finger and then smell your
finger
and right in right now
wait are those the spicy chips this
isn't the chip yeah one of them is that
chip get it started
yeah it's not that bad yeah just want to
say something I beat you
I know you have a hard time with spicy
so yeah
came back from a two-week vendor ain't
really good
wow it's remember water is not just
water and stay hydrated my friends love
each other and dehydrated we might just
go grab a drink all right let's go I
want to check audio audio on Dave you
and my audio where's he we have audio
Yeah give a shout out to Zach say Zach
you give him a bingo
you tend to be histrionic all the time
[Applause]
no Olivia wait I look kind of slay right
now yeah you do yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
when my friend Neil bent over this
happened does somebody know is this
covid related and if it is what do we do
about it
ow oh no no no
[Applause]
[Music]
um
actually you know what's the most
important ingredient on the H3 podcast
people hmm
and then the pizza wow there's nobody
nobody
Does it Like Us
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh thank you oh you guys should stand up
thank you guys thank you so much
yeah I want to say
you know
I'm the tip of the iceberg
I don't know if that's a weird analogy
but these guys especially today and all
year round put in so much work
um that a lot of what we do is all
thanks to all these guys is super
amazing and hard work I thank you guys
so much best crew crew the game
best crew
in the game
thank you guys we got the best fans in
the games no question about it no
question
nobody else can make two
two uh credible that I'm just kidding
two credible death threats and still
have people here to support me
yes
about to make a third
stop it
you know who you know who I'm talking
about
no I'm just kidding
what
oh yeah I know what be realist you want
to be real me right now
sure I'm not doing anything
[Music]
yeah it's all good hey I'm
divarell what's up yo cool all right
yeah we did a b-real
[Music]
um
whoa what the [ __ ] was that
how'd you get his phone
wait what how'd you get his phone
wait what there's what are you guys
doing which phone is that
wait why are you throwing your phone up
are you crazy
anyone else want to throw their feet
don't no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no I don't want anyone's phone
yeah
no you just got your b-rail don't give
that up
you guys want to see the arm Shield pump
yeah
Works in person too it's incredible
yeah but I just want
what's that pounding is that us huh
my arms turned down the building yeah
but anyway guys I just want to thank the
crew I want to thank everyone we've had
such a great year
thanks bro love you guys so much
really love you guys man I can't express
it enough we've had such a great year
here on the podcast everything's really
coming together and
very much looking forward to next year
we're gonna have more Goofs more gaps
bigger better
stronger
more death threats more Bob threats
okay no no let's maybe just back it up
that one yeah
okay just the death threats part we're
gonna have the kill switch next year
baby yes there we go
all right I'll stop I'll stop what's up
sorry I know it's a bad impulse to keep
making fun of them
how do I get out of this
yeah anyway
you flew here from Minnesota wow
that's why I knew I had to do this [ __ ]
yeah
yeah anyone here from America anyone
from Arizona Arizona anyone here from
Arizona
what yeah
oh
you're in trouble does someone want to
Dan I don't want to run I'm just a
surprise or something there is one last
little surprise at the end here yes
there and where are they
who are they it's a good question is it
this guy with his hand up
Olivia's got it what is that
it's what wait hold on thank you
a steak oh you got it all wrapped up
hell yeah wait wait wait okay
Lorenzo and Jessica
Lorenzo and Jessica I think Lorenzo
wants to ask you something Jessica wait
where are they wait hold on hold on hold
on
hold on where are they
oh the balcony
on the balcony y'all better get down
here jump yeah I'm just kidding this
isn't no Travis Scott concert
everybody rushed the stage no I'm
kidding please
we're we don't [ __ ] we're low energy
crowd
no they're really on the balcony yeah
we're sending the camera
goddamn
I thought they were going to come up on
stage
they're coming they're coming they're
coming here we go here we go
is there an easier way up
here go with go Shannon yeah go around
so
what's happening what's happening
[Music]
hey dude what's your name
nice to meet you from Phoenix Arizona
[Applause]
are there Gators in Arizona none ball
what's your name anymore bro Jessica do
you know why you're up here okay I love
the hoodie that one's fire
yeah let's take a photo here
[Applause]
say
get the selfie priority say flu
okay up here I'll let you take the mic
take the mic actually give him a non I
don't want you yeah it's not my surprise
for the past few months I've been
talking to Olivia and kind of
choreographing this in a little bit of
sense I just wanted to express my love
to you and I asked you in front of all
of our Koopa Troopers here family family
family
[Applause]
[Applause]
congratulations
that's how we do it
you did did you even ask her though you
didn't ask the question I think he did
oh you did okay sorry sorry I didn't
mean to ruin the moment I
did you answer
okay okay let's make it true yes yes yes
yes yes
hell yes
nice ring dude
he's a keeper
asked me to marry you ask me uh
oh nice congratulations you guys
thank you so much thank you Olivia yeah
if it wasn't for you guys just like our
relationship like has brought us so much
closer together if it wasn't for your
guys's podcast so and all honestly thank
you guys and thank you poop thank you
family like I appreciate this at the
bottom of my heart
[Music]
congrats guys
[Applause]
it's beautiful you know what's funny
[Music]
at our last live show there was an
engagement
and they're still married
so you know congrats guys yes I love it
congratulations congratulations
amazing
and uh yeah that's a crazy ring
and uh was there a question that you
wanted and I'm just kidding
just happened someone just [ __ ] their
pants right there
all right
thank you guys
God bless y'all
um I don't know how you I don't know how
you guys got up over here yeah okay cool
thanks anyone want a crowd surf
no
dude we're actually on time Dan isn't
that crazy
I'm doing it it's arguable are we over
it says 9 50 N or 11.50 we're all right
we're all right we've got to go though
congrats guys love y'all yeah so guys we
will be back January 16th
[Music]
I will be doing Tuesday episodes though
for the Super Troopers yes thank you
guys
but uh from the bottom of my heart I
want to thank you guys
I want to thank you guys
yeah I want to thank everyone too thank
you so much for everything that you guys
do for us all the support and all the
kind words that you guys always
um share with us it's just it meant so
much to us thank you
I'll say hi but
I think I might be dying
so I'm probably just gonna leave but
next time
hey guys
thank you I love you guys so much thank
you thank you so much get she's saying
get me sick you want me to cough in your
face
no no no no no no no no no no no no
oh okay all right thank you guys by the
way
by the way does any you guys wanna does
anyone want to say anything
I want to hear from you you got anything
all right thank you guys the fans for uh
I think changing all of our Lives thank
you Ethan and Nila for the years you
guys put into YouTube and uh creating
this wonderful audience that you have
just to share it with us we uh we are
not worthy thank you so much love you
guys
foreign
[Music]
I I started here when I was 20 years old
oh my God and I'm 25 now wow it's a long
time that's a long time you started with
no Rolex
so much has changed but
Ethan Anila you guys
like gave me everything
you gave me
and a platform for me to be my crazy
weird [ __ ] up self IE
I humbly accept so thank you seriously
I love you both I love the whole crew
yeah you guys are amazing cheers to uh a
happy New Year yeah
all right guys
that was fun we'll do this again yeah
this was really fun
sorry I wish I could say hi to everyone
I really I think I am dying feel my
forehead
oh [ __ ]
seriously I'm not hot
all right I guess I'm staying
I'm just saying no fever
all right guys listen thank you
everybody uh we'll see you next year
bye everybody thank you thank you for
coming
thank you